it is april 22 friday baby
join oh yes yes yes yes yes
oh i just kind of felt a little bit
hawaii today so okay
loving that for you
thank you joined by ela of course which
is why we love fridays so well ela how
are you thank you i'm good now that i'm
here
forget all worries
do you really
no i was like wow
you really love doing the show
i do love it though
all my worries are gone the minute dan
pushed that live button yeah the minute
i hear that two
one well i'm happy to first of all
thank our wonderful sponsors what what
what what what what what what what what
mint mobile
thank you to mint mobile our one and
only sponsor
is saving more spending less is one of
your top goals for 2022
why are you still paying insane amounts
of money right every month for wireless
switching to mint mobile is the easiest
way to save this year as the first
company sell premium wireless service
online only mint mobile lets you
maximize your savings with plans
starting at just 15 bucks a month dan
uses that it's the same stuff it works
just as good it's just cheaper if you're
using a major carrier you're being
scammed true that's true you can use
your own phone with any mint mobile plan
and keep your same phone number along
with all your existing contacts and with
mobile choose the right amount of
monthly data that's right for you and
stop paying for data you never use it
get your new wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month and get the plans shipped
right to your door for free go to
mobile.com slash after dark that's
mintmobile.com cut your wireless bill to
15 bucks a month at mintmobile.com after
dark thank you thank you okay
well done well done
how far you come on those ad
yeah you know wherever you are you know
we used to do
the ad reads were brutal back back back
in the day 10 minutes
if that
remember when we started doing
pre-recorded that's when it got real bad
that was when it got real bad
rewind time ethan would stumble and be
like let's just start over and we'd do
that like 10 times god yes sometimes we
sit there for like 30 minutes right now
it's brutal
yeah you just blast through
look at me i've come such a long way
what's the title of this episode the
title is johnny depp
adams
okay that's all we got
that's all we got you want to call it
beans on toast extravaganza that way i
mean i feel like that's more interesting
than johnny depp aiden ross kim k damn i
can change it to beans on toast special
the beans on toast extravaganza man
we can think of a we can think of a
title maybe uh
don't actually do that dan oh
beans on toast do you think that's a
better title i didn't okay
people want the fit check
for ela not me right well
not me i don't have a fit check but yeah
show them off because you got that teddy
fresh drip that looks yo that [ __ ] looks
really good wait why do you have a
pacifier necklace that's kind of weird
it's a raver
no remember like the little pacifier
thing like as a necklace
yeah what have you ever seen that trend
people used to do that i've seen this
pacifier candy
no that was a very two thousand oh
people used to do that i didn't know
that i just i associate it with like
ecstasy
it's a little related it's not but it's
a little like party i guess
party attire something about adults with
pacifiers just gives me an it because it
reminds me of like age no sun like
diaper [ __ ] no
totally misread what's next a necklace
with a diaper so i was gonna say now
that i'm a mom kind of have a little
like new meaning to it right that's that
mom
um it's mom bling
that's kind of an interesting design
nothing icky here i'm just saying it
just i don't like seeing a mobile core
like mom core aesthetic mom core okay
i'm just saying like in general
adults with baby stuff is an ick i'm not
i think it's fine i'm just saying like
if i see someone at a concert with a
pacifier in their mouth
i don't like it
okay well this is pretty far from having
it and then and then they're going like
this
yeah
good time you know they're having fun
though yep
my jaw hurts just from that you do that
for like hours
oh so okay before we get started
really interesting announcement
so we made
uh a little project with
an artist called raptrading.co
that's where they're located that's his
website that's his website i don't know
what's what's his well he just goes by
rap trading right so yeah rap trading
dot com his name's raptrading
and we made h3 trading cards i'm trying
to get the right angle
and this is just a fun project we're not
trying to make money or anything the
price is super low
everyone's going to make money from this
it's but it's it's really just a fun
project
and we made we only made like 350 cards
because it was just
it was whatever well we posted it on
twitter this morning and they already
sold out
so what we're going to do for everyone
who wants to get their hands on it's
only 25 bucks i don't know if i
mentioned that and you get all these you
get all these cards
get all of or yeah there's a there's a a
pack on the table too if you want to
show what the the packaging looks like
yeah i'll open that but yeah it's like a
little booster pack
it comes in a whole booster pack here
and
they're really cool
it's like the whole tr it's pokemon
cards but podcast you see the back of
the pack what it says
the back of the pack says five percent
off
you can't read it really on camera
is there any rare like uh ethan mander
uh special edition
ethan charmander i think they're all
foil so but the ethan is definitely
that's a top tier card like if you get
it if you get that one rated as like a
10 that'll be worth at least like 30
dollars well we're only going to do this
one
maybe maybe if you're lucky five percent
um but but basically
uh yeah it's just a one-time thing but
we opened it up for
because they sold out immediately and i
want everyone to get one who wants one
uh
if you go to raptrading.com
we're take we'll take pre-sales
for how long how long are we going to do
that for like a week or something i
don't know yeah i think
probably a week yeah
so we'll leave it open for a week and it
will take like four to six weeks to
produce and ship them so if you don't
mind waiting four to six weeks
then you can still get a pack
at uh rap trading dot co and i just
added the link to the description which
i should have done before and the whole
gang's here i wish you uh i wish i could
show a better
a better
angle on it uh i could you could post on
socials
but you know it's got everyone
who's my favorite oh the ethan's feet i
mean that's a collectible that one is my
favorite
your feet i'm glad we're able to
monetize that image because i do love
that and it's so sad that that i'm still
sad the wikifeet
war is over we lost
i love cams
wait a minute
the uh
cam just linked our instagram post it's
got uh it shows them all oh you want to
just show that yeah
you sure because i'm holding this okay
roll it i mean
i mean you get the idea right you can
see them all on the website i'm sure
on rap trading
but here you go they're shiny
they're beautiful
it is what it is and it ain't what it
ain't right maybe right
here's the pack they come in this there
you go raptrading.com so
fun
it's a fun project isn't
it then
can you reply like that to in it
it is it didn't it didn't i mean i mean
sure
yeah you can
do anything you want
coop
uh oh bts thank you to members
members members man what is this you
have a trailer amy
yeah i put together a little a couple
minutes showing this is a little preview
for this week's behind the scenes uh
members get access to a exclusive bts
it's for all of our lovely members this
week we will have creators featured such
as idubbbz anissa minx esfen michael
reeves friend of the show eric from
internet comment etiquette wanna get
some nachos and some wine
and much much more including some light
sparring between me and idubbbz about to
sparrow with items live on xband's
stream
no pressure just millions of people see
this video amy said before this
he's too much of a fan so he doesn't
want to punch me in the head so you guys
got a chant
in the chat
punch idubbbz did you really tell him
that
i told him
don't get jealous the symptom though the
symptom is real the symptom is a disease
dumb [ __ ]
[Laughter]
some actual training footage of me for
those who have been asking
all day
did you do all day all day baby anyway
uh you guys get it it's all there it's
all happening
check it out thank you ab yes
and i apologize that i don't have the
other members of the squad in this one
but yeah this one was a lot it's all a b
all the time interesting
oh i don't know just put it on a show
three shows a week yeah they see it you
guys were drunk the other day i couldn't
record [ __ ]
you were sober
yeah i know but i mean what am i going
to
drunk hooligans that's awesome yeah what
the [ __ ] yeah
no you know what zach just wanted to
keep grabbing the bottle and standing in
front of the camera
that bts wouldn't exist without a b so
you if you want to film your [ __ ] and
put it up there i don't care appreciate
it
just a close-up of your [ __ ]
for 20 minutes
i'd probably actually get more views
yeah you have to become a member to find
out
a b only fans on uh h3 podcast members
got big dick energy
big dick energy but a small dick
that's what he that's what he said maybe
his words anyway whatever let's move on
um
yo yo yeah yeah yeah yo yo zack you got
sick after our last uh guess who's drunk
us who's high i was a hammer dude yeah
it was rough it was a rough uh
it's a rough evening yeah
yes you watched that i loved that
episode it was so much fun but zach got
hammed up and um
yeah i was uh the minute the camera
stopped i could tell that he was already
coming down hard yeah it was uh i was
just wasted dude it was bad
how'd you feel ian yeah
like [ __ ] i felt so really god yeah
we're all getting so old
i was kind of trying to drink to match
zach
but zack's like a big dude
and probably has a higher tolerance for
me so um yeah i uh i could barely open
my eyes
whoa
yeah you held it together well i didn't
realize you were that trashed not at the
time but that night i was like
i i had like an ice helmet on and oh my
goodness you did yeah it was killing me
i had those spins when i got home really
bad
so that was fun jesus you know you know
how i felt
and you feel me completely [ __ ] fine
wow daniel sword which is why
weed is better than alcohol
okay then okay dan i'm just saying
just saying
all these guys are hungover zach called
in sick
that didn't come in a workout that's
fair enough because i mean it was for
the show so yeah but uh but it was
really fun um
hearing about everybody's
like dads and family and things like
that and also sad uh to hear about
kimmely
kimmely cameron
um it was a great episode yeah it was a
great
episode
well we've got a great episode here
today in fact you know we've had trouble
with our sponsors we have one today
which is great
uh but actually a new one reached out to
me on twitter last night
around what when was this sent
at 10 p.m
what the [ __ ] is this
steak.com
the crypto
the crypto gambling site that we're
constantly
uh
talking [ __ ] about they're the ones who
have a hut and barbados
uh
yeah i know i'm just
well daddy
uh they're the ones that have a hut and
curacao
and are sponsoring drake and all this
nonsense they're they're like two weeks
i mean maybe like two years away from
being incarcerated and being on the run
from the fbi
they tweeted this out to me
h3 podcast sponsored by steak
from their fit i was just like is this
how they're
is this them like hitting back at us
they're trolling you for sure but it's
so bad it's like such a bad stupid meme
you think if you're gonna swing back you
do something more interesting than this
i just think it's interesting
um
them posting this
clearly means that that whole thing that
we did bothered them it's on the radar
you know what i mean like
before this i would have assumed that
they had no idea that that discussion
was even happening but they know because
the chances that peop the people who own
steak
are just they're running this like
billion dollar company they're just some
like mid 20 year old [ __ ] who
stumbled into this from one from the
previous scam to the next and it ended
up getting bit like way too big and now
they're like we own steak from a hut and
curacao
like tell me
bad tell me whoever you are that owns
steak.com i tweeted this did you tweet
this from your hut and curacao or your
[ __ ] penthouse in toronto or wherever
the [ __ ] you live
you know
i'll be laughing when you go to jail
though
and by the way you got to work on your
photoshop skills my dude yeah that's
some dog [ __ ] right there
so so but then did they also made a hut
joke
well i think isn't it
behind you oh okay so that's the image
but
they do they are making a hot joke right
wait did they edit that or was that from
the episode we did
oh they edited that yeah yeah
so
that's all i think they're good
the whole thing is so odd
[Music]
yeah so guys go over to steak.com if you
want to be able to never get your money
out
and have untraceable crypto deposits
i guess now he's just having a big joke
out of it
yeah i would rather [ __ ] die than
take your blood money to be honest
not die let's not put it down partially
i'd rather take money from who would i
rather take money from god i'd rather
take money from alpha brain
hmm you know what i'm saying
yeah i guess i guess so can we do a
shitty sponsor like a
a shitty sponsor tier list that could be
the worst like there's alpha brain
there's like um
there's
you know steak
relative
yeah or just triller trailer trailer's
fine i mean that's it's honestly fine
there's like nothing wrong with that
you hear that trailer if you wanted to
pay if ryan wanted to pay me i'd happily
take his money be like yo apparently
there's an app
called triller could you imagine just
one day you're suddenly
pretending you've never heard of them
before i just found out about this great
new app guys there's a great new app
called triller it's really exciting it's
going to knock tick tock on its feet
miller my thing's flipped
well anyway what about fashion nova
i would definitely never work with
fashion nova but but steak fashion nova
i think steak is worse i think it's
worse okay what do you think hila
um i'll just follow your lead because i
don't know much about 801 well at least
with fashion nova you get something for
your money i mean that's not
pro i mean i'm sure you can get your
money from steak are you sure yeah i
think the biggest well the biggest
problem with steak is that they're
clandestinely
advertising to literal children on
twitch why are you sure you can get your
money out from because it's so
i mean millions of people use it there
would be
people talking about that all the time
a problem with drawing money from steak
i'm sure it's fine stick your finger why
are you so sure if who paid you who got
to you dad i see dan playing the
roulette sometimes i see check's in the
mail right someone got today i i i
i see him playing roulette he's like
come on baby let's go let's go
yo by the way 82 likes massive pull for
this platform
but don't you think like if you're
following steak and you're like a fan of
this huge
casino
and they're [ __ ] posting memes i just
find that a little
questionable
like are they really going to pay you
out if they're [ __ ] posting memes
i don't know
we're seeing a small
amount of reddit posts saying they're
having problems with drawing their money
but okay like
not that much no okay i mean the thing
is that they don't have any money to
withdraw they lose it all that's the
point
right
it's rigged before
that's a really good point love
yeah who who's withdrawing money from
gambling exactly
steak
now can we talk about
some really interesting stuff you don't
mind sure
i wanted to give um
the people an update that we have
watched and still watching
the real housewives of potomac right oh
lots of housewives fans i guess in the
in the
go yeah they were heavily suggesting
that one because that's the one that
that won
the
poll that we did yeah which one we
should watch
so we've been watching it we watched
like we're on season six now we started
at one wow
it's probably not been worth it it's
been a lot of work it is
there's been some payoff but i can't say
it's been worth it salt lake city is
just the best those ladies are so nuts i
think potomac i mean these ladies are
pretty crazy but those salt lake city
ladies are on i don't know
it's just it's a lot of investment you
really gotta sit there and just listen
to these women these vapid [ __ ] women
talk about [ __ ] for a long time
before they start pulling each other's
hair
which did happen that did happen one of
them got into the actual fight
and uh she started pulling her hair
and they're they're black women so she
like pulled her wig off and [ __ ]
and
they filed dueling police reports for
second degree assault i mean this sounds
pretty juicy no that was great but i'm
telling you but it took like multiple
seasons to get to this bro five
okay yeah that's a lot of build up but
like that moment was great like straight
up pulling hair
[Music]
and then the producers break them up
and then one of the girls runs around
the back and tries to attack her again
she's like oh give me that page
okay that's pretty epic and like
demonically possessed and they would
never apologize to each other and um
one of them got kicked off the show she
just mysteriously disappeared after
season five the one that attacked her
that was good that was good
so
the biggest thing is that beverly hills
comes back
in may
are we already in may it comes back in
may no no yeah
and
that one is going to be fire
i don't care about it yes you do always
erica jane
that's true i am interested so erica
jane is one of the beverly hills
housewives
and she is she's in my opinion the most
annoying of them from the beginning
she's married to this big time super
rich lawyer
and
she has this like horrible music career
i mean she's like 40 and she's trying to
become a pop star she has no talent and
they're just
pouring millions and millions of dollars
into her
absolutely failed musical career i know
that yeah i know about it even i've
never seen the show but yeah and the
lawyer
yeah i'm getting to that right it's like
a crazy story right very crazy i think
we may have already talked about it on
the show but so it came out in the last
season
that her husband the super rich lawyer
was actually so when he he's like
he does like big settlement cases for
people who get injured and stuff
class actions
and how it works is
when you win a judgment for a big amount
of money it goes into what's called like
a settlement account or a
it's like an escrow account
where the lawyers aren't allowed to
touch it there's like very strict rules
set by the bar
and he had developed this really
elaborate
devious scheme
where he was convincing some people that
he was going to invest the money for
them
and convincing him he was like this
money manager yeah because one of the
victims for example was a kid it was
young so he was convincing them that
he's for them will keep the money so
that
they have it like in a secure place and
and not waste it all quickly or
something
and then
the kid never actually got all the money
he never got any of it and it was like
and he ended up having stole like 100
million dollars from his victims
and the thing that's so crazy about it
is that erica his his dumb
his dumb talentless wife is in the show
living the most extravagant life
every outfit is like full designer like
20 30 000 outfit she drives a
rolls-royce they spend so much [ __ ]
money on her music video this i cannot
tell you how talented this this woman is
i want to show you one of her videos but
then all of a sudden
it comes out that her husband is a
horrific
criminal and thief
and now it's all going down on the show
and what's interesting is there's like
how much did she know how much she
didn't know and even if she didn't know
she's living fat on stolen money yeah
even if she didn't know it's just like
the
the fact that it's all on video and
you're watching her
she's always dressed in like the
drippiest drippiest [ __ ] yeah all brands
high-end brands all the time
and then the last season was really
interesting because it was after
everything was happening
and and she was just so focused on
herself still
which was
non-apologetic
like just yeah she never talks about the
victims it's just all about how poor
erica she's the worst she's the worst i
hate her
and uh but it's really interesting to
watch it all go down i have to say the
housewives as far as reality show is
pretty ester the [ __ ]
that goes down there's always someone
getting arrested for tax evasion
somebody pulling someone's wig off
i mean there's like literal [ __ ]
felonies happening you know in salt lake
city like we said like the fbi straight
up came and picked one of the ladies up
out of the party bus because her ass was
committing like wire fraud she was like
scamming old people it's nuts you want
me to take their money
she was doing like lead generation and
then contacting old people and stealing
their money
like scamming old people it's [ __ ]
crazy dude
it's awesome
so here here's erica jane by the way
just
[Music]
go ahead and claim this would be your
only revenue stream
let's say we all yeah [ __ ] well here i'm
just gonna cut forward
[Music]
no she's horrible she's disgusting
she's horrible she's disgusting she has
no talent the whole thing is about like
i have money
and it's like this money is stolen from
victims it's just great well she never
worked a day in her life and then the
thing is she'll go on tour
and she'll spend money because nobody's
there there's not enough people buying
tickets but she spends so much money to
put on the show that every show she does
she loses money so she spends it costs
her money to go on tour and she does it
because she wants to be this
pop star
awesome right how old is she
she's got to be
in her 40s 50s she's got to be mid-40s
she's 50.
there you go you gotta use your 50 year
old trying to break in as a pop star you
guys
stop
stop it
oh look look i wonder this goes erica
jane american singer hell no
that is not what you are
yeah i love it
so there you have it you know
is this kid's choice award
damn oliver tree you got beat up by
erica james mtv
um
oh in the same kind of a universe
rudy giuliani was on the math singer
you know
yeah which is kind of fun it's like
bringing out um
char it's like you know if
if uh
you know
charles manson came on or something and
it's a sexual dance it's like nobody
would see it coming
uh
he's such a disg why are they doing this
why are they trying to make like these
[ __ ] traitors cute
is that a older clip it was during the
height of [ __ ] it wasn't even it
just aired
but it was shot during like the outside
the sex shop trying to overthrow the
election era i think right then the i
think so i'm trying to find exactly when
it was recorded i know it was
they were sitting on it for a good while
before it erred disgusting
yeah
actually a few the judges walked off
which i thought it was good really yeah
you'll see it in this clip so they
didn't know that it was gonna come well
that's the whole point is you have to
guess who's there
okay i never watched this well who the
[ __ ] would guess rudy giuliani my god
well that show like keeps it so like
secret like it it's very
very intense on how secret they keep
the contestant being on
and today the mass singer is
um
a little
nas
doing a sexual dance
a sexual sexual dance anal
sex o.j simpson
as stabby the knife
[Applause]
he's bailing he's like i'm done i'm done
[Music]
but you get the idea
i don't know if he's walking out because
it's rudy i think he's walking off
because it was just [ __ ]
i think he walked out because it's rudy
yeah well yeah of course but
he's like i'm done with this [ __ ]
i just don't
what the [ __ ] happened to television i
stopped watching like five years ago
that's kind of the truth isn't it like
we have um
we have directv or whatever but we never
use it
never
who would be your favorite
um
mass singer contestant
a housewife
introducing
from maximum
security state penitentiary
i would want your favorite sexual
criminal what karen from potomac
james charles and on his shoulders a
12 year old boy who is the the housewife
that went to prison for i think it was
tax evasion i think housewives in new
jersey oh yeah we haven't watched new
jersey yet oh god there's too much of
this [ __ ] it's crazy her and her husband
i think yeah i heard that yeah i heard
he there went to jail yeah but yeah i
heard they actually just went to the
slammer and tax evasion happens and
pretty much you can bet one
character in every season is going to
jail for for even in potomac like
evasion didn't happen but two of the
characters were
having articles about them not paying
taxes well and then they had to pay it
but
hey what's up hello uh what's up gabe
let's go
it's friday and we're cruising baby
cruising cruising down the street in my
sixth floor slapping the b words
hitting the h's
careful careful
that's a vulgar song there buddy
how you doing how you doing where are
you driving to
we're going to coachella really
are you serious
are you performing
what is it are you performing
i'm i'm watching oh you're watching i'm
watching and partying
what artist are you going there to see
specifically i'm trying to see the
weekend baby
and baby
okay okay
is this your coachella outfit
is that your drip because they're
supposed to dress up all drippy for
coachella is that your drip
we got we got it it's in my um suitcase
oh
can you i want to make sure to see what
outfits you wear when you go
i want to see your drippy outfit
yeah
it's friday baby friday for coachella
friday's for coachella baby
are you gonna meet some girls there or
are you just gonna take it easy
hopefully someone i like
oh yeah
yeah
well
how far of a drive is it from i know you
guys live in l.a how far is it it's in
palm springs
two and a half hours okay that's not bad
markers of traffic
that's not bad what do you drink to keep
awake when you drive you chug reg bowls
you like to coffee what do you do just a
coke just a coke that's good you're a
sweet man you're a good man
diet or regular
okay regular yeah good man good man yeah
wow
hell no hell no
regular oak is kind of hardcore
vadilla
regular coke that's pretty hardcore yeah
it is hardcore that i mean they're i i
i'm past the days of my life where i can
drink regular coke but gabe's hardcore
gabe is hardcore
that stuff keeps me awake i don't need
coffee just just to cook and i'm good
i think your feed died but we can still
hear you oh
gabe is headed to coachella he's always
off that man is always up to something
yeah always people in the chat pointed
out of course he's going for the weekend
he's all about weekends right it's a
weekend baby
that's a good observation yeah
he lives for the weekend
um
so
uh uh by the way before we move on um we
have this little uh beans and toast uh
taste test thing oh my god it's gonna
take sam about ten minutes to prepare
for putting this off okay
why are you putting it off so bad well
we were talking about how english bread
breakfast is just horrid was that after
the show or on the show it was on the
show it was a little bit on the show but
we had conversation continued we had a
really
in-depth
conversation after the show about how
disgusting english breakfast is and cam
was looking at it like he thought it was
a troll i was like bro that's serious as
a heart attack like people act they eat
that [ __ ]
i said that's why they thought you are
so
against it because
mexican food has been
now that said the pictures of it look
horrific this is these are this is
picturesque
look this is i just typed traditional
english breakfast yeah i mean that looks
good except for the blood pudding [ __ ]
blood wait wait wait we were finding
some really funny pictures
um but
look at this [ __ ] that that that's
[ __ ]
a plate of baked beans
what did you call that pet as soldiers i
don't know i kind of don't see it as bad
as you are i think maybe it's because
americans have this association with
baked beans they're like sweet
smoky beans and it just i can't imagine
those flavors mixing it's just
disgusting it's just weird to me when
you're so about mexican food it's like
this is how open-minded it is oh my god
this is not this is nothing like mexican
why would you even say that i like it
but being beans and breakfast is very
bizarre to begin with but you already do
that this is baked beans this sweet it's
disgusting
see when i yeah because when i look at
like
that's everything yeah i mean that looks
bomb and that's yeah not that that's
violence it's beautiful it's it's the
flavors are there it's not sweet nasty
[ __ ] beans on white bread
okay so one of the 10 eggs
together it's kind of a fire combination
not those beans so here's one of the
things that they do okay that that we
think is extremely great it's baked
beans on toast
i'm sorry but this is [ __ ] if you ever
looked at an english person you're like
look at this guy this is what that's why
they look like that it's because they
eat this
and i what and i love my english fans so
don't take me back
i love i love the english look at this
what the [ __ ] is that
oh my god well anyway we've been talking
a lot of [ __ ] about the english and we
love the english don't we folks well
i wish that i had an english accent
you know it's like decent is interfering
he's fighting back that's fine here what
is he saying he's putting the english
flag
oh here
okay
queen the elizabeth pass the beans
please darling
oh i just [ __ ] my knickers
[Music]
um
so anyway
beans and toast is one of the most foul
dishes in my opinion so we're going to
test it out sam has prepared some beans
on toast and we're going to try it out
american breakfast is also kind of
bizarre
i mean it's disgusting but it's bomb
it's like very unhealthy but it's both
so unhealthy you guys eat pancakes for
breakfast oh yeah we do and you know
what how do pancakes taste
amazing it's not breakfast food then why
do you order it when we go you get on a
birthday party then why do you order
pancakes when we go out for breakfast
because it's america
called out
i have no you're right you're you're
right i mean listen no nobody gonna
i always do yo how does that work
breakfast how's that look right there
boy
beans on toast five stars
that's a five star recipe israeli
breakfast is the best breakfast
what does that consist of usually
probably the same thing yeah i was gonna
say i feel the same middle eastern
as best practice you know what's just
confusing me is the english colonizer
the english colonized the whole [ __ ]
world and this and they and this is all
they got out of that
they picked up all the spices all the
cuisines they could have been the
perfect melting pot and no this is what
racial supremacy looks like this is why
you tell white supremacists you're wrong
and you'll always be wrong because this
is what you eat for breakfast you're
[ __ ] in the head multiculturalism
forever goodbye
i am of course
a white supremacist okay
let me type israeli breakfast yes just
to represent you let's represent it's
just which is okay
that's not a typical you mean like this
no that's nice right yes
what are you looking at billions yeah
you open zoom in on that
all right you get a solid
if you guys heard about that salad for
breakfast
eggs with herbs
some healthy yummy bread that is not dry
some grape leaves
some
healthy tasty cheeses all kinds of them
olives
things healthy
chee no i'm joe i'm just joking about
how eela described it
some healthy beautiful yeah like cottage
cheese some wonderful enriching
jam garlic cheese it is most it is much
healthier though i'm just kidding way
healthier than a pile of pancakes but
that cheese ain't healthy come on but
it's like part of a balanced meal it's
balanced yeah it's part of a balanced
meal
but it is very nice you get like
guacamole sour cream lemonade tabouli
salad
cottage cheese the cottage cheese in
israel is way better by the way
grape leaves love the herbs it's just
the omelet in israel middle east
it's not what we think when you order
omelette they're like cheese
[ __ ] bacon sausage let's go and in
israel and probably all in the middle
east omelette just means like egg
it's just egg and then if you want herbs
which is like cilantro and parsley
and dill
then they put it in there
yeah it's a great meal i agree it's
great so yes i am throwing shade
at
food
in general
and it might be because my mom just went
back
to israel and i'm very bitter about
having nothing to eat again
because she's been cooking for you guys
the last couple months yeah that's fair
i cook for you every night no you do but
you know my mom's gone
okay
just saying somebody said british canned
beans are not quite as sweet as the
american version beans on toast is good
get over it ethan well i'm gonna try it
right now we're going to try it and we
we got the the heinz the blue can that
seemed to be we did a little bit of
research and that seemed to be the
definitive one for beans on toast i'm
sorry if you disagree with that don't
yell at me
that's what we're working with here
here's lebanese breakfast baby you were
telling me about it
you got the that's our stuff
what is this
uh that's why a cheese pie a cheese pie
yeah
ship new pie they're so good
i love it olives vegetables
mint yeah it's mediterranean you know
it's like it's nice
i agree the american breakfast is by far
the most [ __ ] up
but
it is good it is good you see them them
ihops are full as hell on sunday morning
how full are they at like say 2 a.m
ethan
uh lena corrected me
not they're empty which means which is
why you nobody would see me there
see that doesn't look bad but nobody
eats that
uh i mean i eat that that looks bomb no
i would eat that but like that's not a
dish you would get at a restaurant
i'm telling you that that's like what i
get when i go to denny's exactly that
you get this is that denny's yeah what's
this [ __ ] potatoes a side of green onion
like it's just a garnish i mean yeah you
don't get garnished
now this is what i'm talking about
people i would eat the [ __ ] out of that
i would [ __ ] that
actually this doesn't even look like in
terms of the really disgusting
calorie meals you can get at denny's
that's not even that bad
um
oh my god back to the english breakfast
look at this nightmare
with those tomatoes what that's just
like a pile of tomatoes piled tomatoes
mushrooms
and that
it's not it's like
this is not healthy this is not healthy
yeah that's not right
okay tell me which one would you rather
know what i love
american
hash browns verse english
um
i i the the the whole thing of like so
many tomatoes really throws me off
what are you supposed to do with so many
tomatoes and why are they on the vine so
if you try to take them off they're just
gonna pop
those look cooked at least the the first
picture just looked like a bunch of
raw tomatoes i'm definitely going
american on this just because
i'm kind of with elon the pancakes thing
i i used to eat pancakes a lot for
breakfast when i was a kid but over the
years it it has kind of occurred to me
that this is sort of a bizarre thing to
be it's so bizarre that's not something
you should eat regularly yeah yeah well
you know pancakes is probably one of the
worst foods you can eat periods it's
literally just flour
and it's like the definition of empty
it's like saying you eat chocolate cake
every morning yeah and then you pour
sugar syrup on it yeah
and by the way and butter yeah hash
browns though
hashbrowns are bomb love that's an
american invent i'm pretty sure
um
i don't know maybe look at that
board yourself until you're on the verge
of vomiting alrighty i do every day
so anyway
as we wait for our
beans on toast
tim polk's been coming after me hila did
you know that
no i'm off twitter
yeah i know congratulations
okay wait the beans on toast is coming
so let's just get oh [ __ ] let's get this
over i urge everybody okay
the movement that then probably started
and many other people just get off
twitter just get off it delete it
i've been dating a lot about it thank
you sam
so here you go
oh we got t wait is there cheese under
it or something
what's that sauce
oh butter
okay so there's but it's a buttered
toast
yeah it looks like beans on it looks
like the picture is that ian approved
like is this ian yeah is this the real
deal authentic i i think it is if the
toast is a little crunch a little
crunchy looks crunchy and butter yes
yeah it's just the right beans
because everyone goes oh they're not
baked beans what are they uh again we
got we got the blue canned
beans that
when i was looking into it it everybody
seemed to indicate the right one the
blue can yeah all right so here we go
baby
to the english to the english empire and
and all the best it can produce
[Music]
i'm half scottish so i'm going to skip
the pretty sweet the toast to the
english but i don't hate it
listen
i wouldn't say i hate it
but
would you eat that would you want to eat
that
let me try going for one more time yeah
really
i've been talking
[ __ ] i gotta say i think this is winning
me over it was pretty good and it's
actually just baked bean there's nothing
these are good for you
not these beans just like cooked in
sugar and syrup and [ __ ] still beans the
thing said it was in tomato sauce
although i agree it tastes pretty sugary
so
probably that it's not that bad it's not
that bad i'll leak grow a little bit
i called my grandma before the show and
asked her i was like what's what's the
deal
it's like
you can get three cans
for two pounds fifty it's quick it's a
good snack
it's filling and it's got a lot of
vitamins that's what she said you see
that's got a lot of vitamins that's why
i like this actually
because it's not just all bad for you
well it's white bread and butter that's
all bad
and then the beans which is are healthy
but they're cooked in
in my head i'm comparing it to going out
for breakfast here and what are my
options usually on the menu a bunch of
stuff i can't i won't eat like sausage
and bacon
and then what else is there on the menu
usually
you would never order this why
okay next time we go for breakfast i
tell them you know what i want some damn
toast and beans they have this here
maybe some places i'm sure do
i don't think you're getting an identity
away from me
my dad said it's kind of like a thing of
like you know when your parents are
working all day and you don't you don't
have a lot of cash lying around you just
get this definitely a nice affordable
feeling
not some big delicacy or anything like
that that makes sense you know it's a
nice affordable kid friendly nice the
earl grey is nice
but overall i definitely
think that it tastes pretty good
[Music]
yeah it's a nice snack
yeah
frankly i i'm gonna
i'm gonna say that i was wrong
it's really not that bad
and especially i can i can see like if
you grew up on it then it'd probably be
even better
i can definitely see that we're learning
and growing here
we're growing
but aesthetically they can do better
aesthetically it's not pleasing there's
a problem there they can do better
visually we have traveled the world
your majesty we have traveled the whole
world we have conquered half of it
we have seen all the exotic foods in the
world and today
we serve to you
baked beans on white toast your majesty
oh hell yeah brother
can you imagine serving that to like uh
i don't know man it's just it looks
weird okay can i tell you what's my next
favorite breakfast um huevos rancheros
oh hell yeah mexican well that's a great
this year
there's no problem with that it's a
great dish the best
yum
all right well there you go guys
beans on toast
you sure you want me to change the title
to the beans on toast
criticism and uh
thesis
breakdown
the truth about beans on toast
tim poole
when i said on the show that we lost
sponsors
by the way thanks to members and people
who buying teddy fresh thank you thank
you when i said we lost sponsors
the right-wing weirdos went on like a
victory lap
like
jordan peterson was right
because he was like ethan what are you
doing you're just you're just uh what
was the jordan peterson tweet that was
like i'm 14 and this is deep maybe you
could pull it up because that's the
context he was effectively saying that
you're
you're gonna reap what you sow yeah kind
of thing
agator you know flaming turd back which
i i i think that statement by him was
like basically i'm 14 and this is deep
like obvious anyone could
anytime anyone get mad at me they'll be
like oh see you're reaping what you sell
and it's always the kind of people that
may spell
it too you rape what you sell oh they
spell so yeah
interesting
like so
yeah interesting
um
but the thing is
i've been canceled a billion times
before i'm gonna get you canceled again
you know what i mean
but
the weird thing that they keep
interjecting that's just not true that
i've continually said
these guys are just about culture war
narrative it's pathetic temple is such a
pathetic loser so let's go back in time
to january when ethan klein deleted
episodes with he had with jordan
peterson
he clearly did this because he was
panicking about getting canceled bro
they're literally i can't i don't know
what to tell you i deleted it because we
[ __ ] on jordan peterson every day and i
thought it was stupid to have those
episodes on
like and and i just don't like the guy i
think he's trash i think he's [ __ ]
weird i think he has horrible takes and
i think he's a detriment to society
and that's why i removed the interviews
nobody had any expectation there was no
demand
nobody cared i did it because i don't
[ __ ] like him and we regularly [ __ ]
on him and i thought it was just stupid
to have those up you [ __ ]
beanie-headed
bald-headed [ __ ] who by the way a light
breeze will give him brain damage his
head is literally open to the elements
that's why he wears a beanie and i'm
gonna get pissed off about it
i don't
know what's so hard to understand that
or to imagine
that basically you can like
get to know someone over the years and
decide you don't you just don't like
them like what happened to us with
peterson we just didn't really
know him that well i don't think he was
as bad then either and that too
and ever since he had his benzo attacks
he's bringing he's got a little couple
screws loose people evolve and we're
allowed to
just not want to have those up
also the whole narrative that like i
cancelled jordan and so now i'm reaping
what i sell how the [ __ ] did i i deleted
episodes from my own podcast how the
[ __ ] did i cancel jordan peterson you
dumb
bro
you gotta screw the top half of your
head on so you can think better
god
he doesn't want his business to fall
apart so he's just like okay fine dude
i'll do whatever i have to ethan what
he's like just didn't happen never
happened this whole [ __ ] insane
uh scenario to justify
either look at this comment i just saw
he his set is literally an incel nice
guy wet dream
all he's missing is the anime body
pillow and a dart board we actually do
have an anime body pillow and tim's is
cool alpha with a samurai sword and a
pistol and a guitar that comment was
directed it said him i think that's got
to be directed at tim
yeah i mean that's true oh because this
is deaf noodles i get it yeah
yes then that makes sense yes i agree
his set is embarrassing bro
just imagine what goes on and if you
could just peer up under his beanie what
goes on the top side of his head
you should have just stood by your
principles would i that's exactly
just edgy comedy free speech and having
conversations with people how about you
[ __ ] worry about what your thing is
and i'll worry about what my thing is
we have never had one of our show
sponsors cancel on us pull out on us in
fact because they already know that
you're a reactionary [ __ ] creep yeah
that's what the only people that sponsor
you are like uh
who who sponsors temple like i can only
imagine like
some vpns or probably that kind of stuff
maybe alpha brain yeah alpha brain
insole brain intel brain
uh
we are sponsored by the uh white
national socialism uh
movement party and we have never lost a
sponsor
top half's of the head for america party
the first sponsor that i had ever had on
youtube virtual shield sponsors virtual
shield who you call it i mean that
sounds like a vpn yeah exactly they
don't care
vpns notoriously don't care they're like
listen
half of our clients are pedophiles and
nazis so we don't care
you know
i'm not going to draw a line in the sand
it is a vpn exactly
vpn's never dropped also if i i had to
guess
i could be wrong on this but like i'm
going to his podcast right now
and um
i'm not seeing very many sponsors well
yeah many sponsors because he's a
reactionary [ __ ]
he's he's a giant piece of [ __ ] i mean
i'm
i'm just spot checking like random
episodes right now going through and
like
none of these have
sponsorship tags and well if he would
have just stood by his principals
maybe he would have sponsors
i mean maybe they do on the audio side
but i'm on his youtube page and i am
so far i have not come across a single
sponsor
no issues despite all the controversies
the lies the smears the manipulation and
i will stand by
what we believe in and what we say and
i'm not gonna play these stupid games
all right guys you know what to do
that's all it takes is being like i've
never lost sponsors it's like all right
guys get to work here i just found one
and it is a
do not message this sponsor it's a keto
powder
oh i won't even say who the sponsor is
yeah that's that's high that's yeah huge
brand
no that's not the name of the brand but
no i know i'm joking he sells keto power
powder of course they're not dropping
you right
the dumber the better that's what
they're [ __ ] that's their whole [ __ ]
they're like the dumber your audience
the better for us
let's not insult poor zach over here
keto powder
i wouldn't use that [ __ ] okay okay i'm
just saying because i know he's an adam
and keto guys it just sounds like keto
powder
i mix my kudo powder with my alpha brain
my gorilla brain what the [ __ ] is keto
powder
it's probably a bulking formula that's
that doesn't have
any kind of it's probably way protein to
be honest yeah i mean but what's the
difference between
whey protein and
oh keto powder nice fine db
thank you i had to verify that before i
sent it okay i want to see here's
another thing that he's sponsored by
those [ __ ] buckets of slop
sponsored by slop doomsday or slot
buckets
my sponsors have never dropped me of
course they haven't the dumber the
better what is that
survival food survival slip starts yeah
it's for the nuclear fallout it's a
spark at a slop
the race war that's big things yeah
kicked off his tim cass irl podcast
tonight with an advert for survival food
i believe is the first time he's done an
ad read on the podcast live he recently
complained to me
that he struggled to attract sponsors
for it oh
damn so this was amen beginning of last
year and that was the first time he had
had a sponsor on the thing so yeah i
mean yeah
i'm sure it is hard to get people to
sponsor yo check it out you see on the
bottom it says please limit two per
household it's too it's in such a demand
they can't even deliver more than two
you guys
jim baker which is not enough slop to go
around jim baker food bucket
right is that a jim baker food box well
it's the same [ __ ] it's the same kind of
thing yeah
i'll tell you right now everything
you're seeing right here is not what's
in there no is it gonna look like you've
seen pigs feed out of a trough that's
what you're gonna be eating fact jesus
is your source
ethan started playing the games getting
started what do you said you show the
video of him eating the slop oh i would
love to oh they made it to slop and
you're complaining about my sponsors
eating slop
and then let's talk about our sponsors
nobody made me eat slop i guess i got
that premium [ __ ] where i don't have to
eat slaw stuff about that
i'll see if i can find it
it's so awesome he chose to get into
business business with these companies
and now he is sitting there saying it
sucks i have no sponsor well look man
you got to stand up for yourself you
can't let these people push you around
so
god he's standing up he's taking down
jordan
peterson episode
because you look duplicitous you look
like you're lying and you look desperate
and so i i hope it works out but hey man
he's such a dumb [ __ ] little [ __ ]
he's just what does that even mean he's
he's acting like i called him and was
like i know what to do bro i got so much
pressure to remove these jordan peterson
things and they're coming after they're
going to come after our sponsors
i can only say i don't know what he
means that i look like a liar
duplicitous
right
with people who will who will uh push
you off that uh metaphorical uh
yes tim i am i am in favor of trans
rights i don't know what to tell you bro
i'm holding to my own principles temple
was actually trending because he tweeted
something yesterday like uh trans women
are never gonna be biological females or
something which was just rage bait like
he's just trying to piss off trans
advocates
that's what he does
he's like why can't i only get slot
buckets to sponsor me
anyway guys i'm tim poole and here i am
eating my slot bucket
did you find it dan
i have not found it oh man
i want to see that so bad
cliff
at any moment
well then i can only say like you should
have you should have prepared for this
you should have expected it it's so easy
to do a show when you can just make up
any scenario you want and then like
critique it
you know he sounds so smart
you knew was going to happen if imagine
this imagine if ethan klein instead of
deleting the jordan peterson episode
came out and said they're telling me if
i don't delete this episode they're
going to pull my sponsors
i will not take out a conversation out
with dr peterson yeah imagine if that
happened except nobody that
dude you're such a car liar he's a liar
he's just a disgusting liar and i've
explained this on the show before too
which makes it even worse
slot bucket boy i mean i don't
necessarily expect him to know that
uh but he's talking like it's fact right
that's the way he's presenting it yeah
you don't i don't expect him to watch
every episode and hear the explanation
but also just don't make up your own
explanation and then get mad about it
that's what he does that's what his
whole show is
anyway speaking of tim's sponsors
safeandreadymeals.com this is a post
from his instagram
he's got a whole closet full of slop
guys he's ready to go
each one is 30 days i don't think that's
enough to get through the apocalypse
i'll be honest with you guys yeah i
don't know
i mean that's like a year or two and
then you're going down buddy look at me
like some kind of prepper
this is what our new work facility
though we works bro are you able to read
and write
look at me
like some kind of prepper
that's the first sentence
look at me like some kind look at i
think it's like look at me like some
kind of prepper
okay this is for our new work facility
though where we expect to have a lot of
people so it's not just for one person
okay abe just sent a link uh his grammar
is just weird
these are the meals i promote on my
channel sometimes and buying supports my
work
yeah
i'm sure you wait what do you got there
it's the website of uh oh this looks
[ __ ] bro look at it this look this looks
like one of those [ __ ]
pop-ups on like when you're on a porn
site yes it's a very nostalgic pop-up it
looks like a straight
scam powered by my patriot supply
oh yeah brother yo this deal will end 11
hours hurry buy it bye bye bye wait
there's only three i can't get two the
clock is ticking
that's when the doomsday happens the
nukes are falling in 11 hours you're
telling me there's orange juice in that
slot bucket
probably
well powder
i guess powdered i was gonna say like uh
what's it called the frozen stuff
concentrate yeah but it you don't freeze
this so
yeah i don't know
i kind of want to buy one of these and
do and then open it up and see what's
actually in there you can do that
although it's deal 700 oh it's 7.50
nope what the [ __ ]
what i mean i guess it's theoretically
food why is it so expensive that's right
isn't that the idea
yeah that's but still damn but what's in
there it's just some beans and stuff
750
apparently pudding and casserole and all
kinds of things if you go by the picture
the days of the greets the great reset
look to be here
we continue to see how fragile our
nation's supply chains are now quickly
shortages are appearing out of nowhere
imagine if that happened at your local
grocery store again
shelves can be picked clean in a matter
of hours we've all seen it happen
repeatedly
americans can see that the world is on
fire they're ordering this emergency
food like crazy which means and they're
like and our shelves are being wiped out
which means you too while you can
coward
if you uh open the link again in a
different browser the deal clock happens
to start over no way
no way no no no no
i doubt no way
this guy is a manipulative library are
they lying to me refresh is to go back
no it'll save it but if you open it in a
different way like if dan opens it sure
yeah wait does that mean that tim
poole's sponsor is lying
no way lying con wait if you do you're
saying like a totally different browser
or a private browser so let me go
incognito
probably if you click control f5 it's
going to refresh with
let's go incognito you didn't do that
you just opened a new you say did you
did not
here i'll just open it
i said new incognito window you didn't
click that you clicked the wrong button
all right now it is you agree oh my god
they're lying oh my god they're lying to
me
sponsors wow that is crazy
guys can you imagine us ever working
with this [ __ ]
i like hell no
doomday prepper slot meals that are even
questionable if you'll get it or not
because this is obviously like a scam
landing page
yo
tim tim's actually live right now you're
not gonna believe this screenshot
oh he's got his jordan peterson uh
a kawaii pillow
oh congratulations you're the 999th
visitor congratulations you want to slot
bucket
damn wait are those the tissues he uses
to jerk off to his jordan pearson pillow
oh i cannot say for sure
it looks like it there's no waifu no no
no waifu no life food
true
damn yo guys they have real testimonials
here bro cam where did you get this
[ __ ] image of
peterson with the lobster around his
neck
guys here's a here's a genuine review
from barb a in texas the food comes in
six huge buckets
i definitely feel safer knowing that my
family and i now have a buffer of food
in case of a shortage
cool so it's 700 for how many of those
one bucket my friend one
or maybe i'm wrong no no no that's they
probably send you like 10.
how many buckets or 10 of these yeah
yeah i mean this is for preppers these
are for these people that think anything
in the world in general who has that
much space
you say you need space and you need
several hundred dollars yeah this is a
website called my
patriot supply what even is this website
what else do they sell here well it goes
in your bomb shelter that's right right
you have to have it so you also need a
bombshell 100 hour candle
i mean it's survival gear it's all stuff
that like but it's the the whole patriot
angle makes me s makes me true patriot
only true patriots understand that the
united states is about to collapse only
people that love their country think
that it's
on the verge of completely i'll tell you
what that joe biden
that's what the reset is coming what is
the great reset
oh that's way too much to get into right
now
you're muted
sorry when you call the number for this
company there's like some epic patriot
music that plays
i want me a dang i need a survival
bucket because joe biden about to hit
that reset button
and we got to watch out for them gators
in arizona
duncan anyone here from arizona oh wait
tim poole sent me
i know you never you'll never drop tim
poole
dr wolfstar says ethan you're once again
attacking youtuber sponsors and teaching
your audience it's all right to do
uh when youtubers don't share your
opinions then you cry when you lose your
sponsors how do you not understand well
thanks for the ten dollars first of all
that's a generous donation actually so
thank you very much first of all nobody
tapped the sponsors okay
but i do think i'm just making a funny
officer this is [ __ ] fun this is
objectively funny i don't know what to
say doctor won't start this listening
this is a funny company temple made a
claim
specifically to me
that none of my sponsors ever dropped me
because i'm true to myself he lied about
me i said okay who are your sponsors
because
you know oh hell yeah oh this is the
slot bucket
oh this is inspiring
trust me no matter what i do
no matter what i say or show the slot
bucket people will never drop tin pool
he's right
so
i th the this has nothing to do with
anything we're just making fun of this
yeah i'm not i'm not it's not that
serious by the way
i don't like so if you're into it go and
buy it you know we're just making fun
yeah go [ __ ] buy the stock bucket if
you want the slot bucket and use code
tim poole whatever i don't i don't think
i don't think not that he's in any
danger of losing uh patriot whatever the
survival
dot co no that's right they will never
leave him yeah yeah they're gonna
sponsor him more now yeah we're talking
about them exactly
maybe there's probably some people
watching right now they're like i need a
[ __ ] slot bucket yeah right we might
have got them some business use a
code pool
yeah or whatever the [ __ ] his code is
sloppy safe and ready meals dot com
i'm really genuinely not this is [ __ ]
funny am i crazy this is funny stool he
called me out i looked at his monsters
this is funny i don't want anyone to go
write them emails and like you rarely
think they would care if you did they
would not have taken down the jordan at
all
by the way in actuality whose sponsors
have i really gone after i mean the
thing with keemstar was again just a
joke where i was like hey look uh
g fuel sponsors this guy who like
bullies people into unaliving themselves
that's pretty crazy
because it was on his [ __ ] desk as
he's telling uh etika why don't you just
jump off her bridge then right i'm like
and i made a joke this [ __ ] unaliving
is sponsored by g fuel that's funny yeah
it's funny thank you it's funny i don't
[ __ ] care dude and then who else
james charles like okay you are david
dobrik like you guys really [ __ ] like
some people shouldn't have sponsors well
and we didn't you never went after
sponsors i don't think i did so i'm an
article i i i
i
i completely reject that notion i don't
really go after people's sponsors
maybe i've done it once or twice in the
case of like james charles or someone
really heinous like that but almost i
don't think i ever genuinely say go
after people's sponsors don't go after
anyone's sponsors i don't [ __ ] care
yeah only go after my sponsors please
thank you
which i i don't even need to tell you
that
you guys you guys got all the initiative
right on your own go-getters all of you
but you gotta admit that slop shit's
funny
it's funny
it's an episode
because you look duplicitous you
i i feel like this is a guy who got
started doing edgy comedy on reddit and
youtube yes things like that and that
bro that was like 10 years ago like can
you [ __ ] move on how long ago was it
that we even made edgy videos on h3
brushes it's literally i think it's
almost been 10 years
and it's like these guys they need to
[ __ ] he's basically telling you who
you are and what you're supposed to be
doing
yeah right like what yeah i'm sorry this
is america mind your own business brah
god damn breath but even if you watch
those old videos i mean yeah maybe the
way you phrased some things was not
right or the language wasn't appropriate
but if you watch them like how many
times how much [ __ ] did you get for
defending those um those black guys and
joey salads video oh yeah like it's it's
crazy if you watch any of those old
videos like that people were unsubbing
calling me a [ __ ] woke liberal [ __ ]
and the only redeeming thing was that
somebody actually leaked
the video of joey faking it and i was
like very satisfied you guys yeah
exactly
that was one of my big wake-up calls
when i did
um
when i made that joey salads fake trump
card thing that was super racist i was
like this is so fake everybody knows
this fake and and then so many people
did it yeah the comments were like you
know this is real ethan like this is
totally real and i was like
holy [ __ ]
these [ __ ] racist freaks we were
watching my videos
yeah
and so much that it became a meme you
know this one's right yeah you know this
one's real ethan that was one of the
comments so it became a meme
but it's like tim you know back in third
maybe you know back in uh when you were
three you used to [ __ ] in the [ __ ]
floor so uh what kind of hypocrite are
you using a toilet
right
you know and as times went on he thought
i just better say what they're saying
the problem is
god he's like he knows me better than
myself he knows everything about me yeah
once again this is not mainstream
america he is bending the knee to
weirdos jordan peterson is popular among
regular people yeah he's also [ __ ]
weirdo sports conversion therapy his
wife or his daughter dates a known human
trafficker he just went to jail just
arrested and he's a uh
he's a [ __ ] weirdo and also he's
cringe he's cringed yeah he's crazy i
mean the worst crime of all of those
things is that he's absolutely cringe
posting cringe is it he's posting cringe
yeah we're gonna do about men what are
we gonna do about men
they're eating out of slop buckets oh
boy
they're buying slot buckets at tim
slot bucket dot com for 750 dollars
they're probably one of my favorite of
all times the what we can do without man
what are we gonna do without tim paul
the top head the top part of his head is
missing
he's loses brain cells every time he
takes his beanie off
we can't let the air reach his brain
[Music]
the man lives on slop buckets for
christ's sake we need to get him real
food
we need to get this man a waifu
he's got a sword and a gun behind him
how insecure can you be man
[Music]
i love that overlay
oh man i'm crying you know tim pool's
head is like gepetto and pinocchio don't
you know
and uh when you know it's a real boy
and tim paul wishes he had the a real
top part of his head
[Music]
have you ever felt a light breeze on
your brain
tim pool does
it's not good for you his brain is out
there doing amazing things temple's
brain is out there doing amazing things
he's actually built calluses on his
brain
[Music]
the people who don't like him are the
fringe weirdos regular people do like
him regular people don't know who the
jordan peterson is are you kidding me
like
i'm sorry i'd know who he is well
unfortunately he didn't honestly me too
yeah unfortunately i think tim er
doesn't realize that the people that
watch his show are the fringe weirdos so
right yeah know it's caught i think you
got lost in the sauce there a little
better
started doing edgy comedy on reddit and
youtube anyway i love that [ __ ]
not have taken down yeah no uh tim poole
says he isn't into
uh i just make up [ __ ] about him yeah so
tim he says he's not into like having
sex with underage kids but like
um
i don't i don't even know how to spend
that
so let's go back in time i need to get
my brain transplant down
pop and clean up those brain sponsors
yeah
out there
welcome to head head cap
for people missing half their dome
we screw it on like a plunger
and you can take off your beanie and
feel there
that's that
thank you tim pool
and shout out to the swap buckets
flop
buckets
ace family claims this is so good now
ela i don't know if you saw we were did
a whole poll
and we were trying to guess
what was going to happen with the ace
family
ace fest no i didn't see that because
they so what happened with ace fest
is that they said it was sold out after
a day
and somebody figured out this really
intelligent way
to figure out how many tickets they
actually sold
it wasn't a lot
[Music]
at all
okay and so we were like roughly 500
right
500 to 600 600 yeah somewhere they sold
600 tickets yeah yeah
each ticket is for like five people or
five people yeah
but they said oh we sold it out we're
like so either they're gonna steal
people's money you're going to cancel
the event
or they're going to open it up and try
to like build hype and be like it was
sold out but we're going to open more
seats
that to that explanation didn't make a
lot of sense to me because who would
want to go to like an overcrowded
right but that's not what they said well
here here we got our answer it was
basically just yesterday they put out a
video
and they answered our question
and with the link it looks like it's
back open guys
let's see it's super exciting that it's
back open
oh no it's sold out again oh it's still
sold out oh no
it's sold out again [ __ ] scammed
okay here it is
friday if you are new to this channel
make sure you hit that subscribe button
and join the family so before we get
into today's video we just want to say
thank you thank you thank you thank you
so much for all of your love and support
we are so excited to do ace fest this
year like this is going to be
an amazing time so going into this
catherine you know we bought tickets
right yeah we got a five packer
yep i can't wait to see what happens
there and it's in palmdale which is like
desolate [ __ ]
and it's in the middle of summer it's
like a desolate
desert
we really didn't have an idea of how
well we were gonna do we didn't know how
many people would want to come to the
a-spec so we kept it at like a smaller
scale than trying to go too big
if that makes sense like we want to keep
it smaller scale and then hopefully grow
it because it's our first time doing
this so when tickets went on sale and we
sold out we were sitting there like they
they're lying
they sold 500 tickets damn
uh maybe we should win bigger maybe it's
you know the right amount of people
um i mean i'm really happy with the
amount of people that are going yeah and
i think it'll be amazing
wait cameron found something interesting
this is on their website still only 5
000 tickets available get one before
it's too late
so it says that despite being quote
unquote sold out
yeah
that doesn't
so did they close it already it's just
so weird okay let me watch the video
it'll be so much fun and like the video
would look amazing but then again it's
like the venue has the capability of
holding a lot more people so with that
being said we were looking at your
guys's feedback
and we noticed a lot of you were unable
to get a ticket because of how fast it
sold out knowing katherine and i
and we told you guys this
number of times it's very hard to please
everyone but
it's super hard to please everyone we
try to please everyone it's just like
but since we do have the capability of
expanding it we're trying our best to do
that for you guys so the people that
were unable to get a ticket
hopefully fingers crossed we literally
just talked to them not too long ago and
we're actually gonna go down and show
you guys
a little bit of the venue today and talk
to them again for you guys and see if
it's possible to make this happen
because we really want
to try to get everyone that's a part of
the ace family who wants to come to be
able to come alright guys so comment
down below in the comment section let us
know if you guys are still interested in
going to ace fashion if you still do not
it looks like it's not open yet maybe
they didn't open it yet but let's see
i s they sticky this i still don't have
tickets and i want to come
sticky that [ __ ]
something's so weird with them i don't
know there's always something fishy
going on
uh
the only comment i see about the one
they stick it is loki feel bad for any
ace family fan who actually bought
tickets to their fest thanksgiving fire
festival yeah i don't see anyone being
like yo i need those tickets
what is the event supposed to be like
what's supposed to be so it's a one day
and it's supposed to be like a carnival
where they have rides
and presents
and
uh live performances
it's just that the financials don't make
any i just can't wait dude i know it's
going to be such a [ __ ] show i just
can't wait
i'm so excited
oh my god somebody just donated ten
bucks said please send some love to the
people in palmdale like me the antelope
valley loves you
shout out paul shut up palm dale palmer
last time we talked about it was
beautiful it's lush
it's
no it is it can be beautiful there's
there's beauty in in the desolation of
the desert you know yeah there's beauty
and death sahara it can be it's there
it's it's entropy and it's uh and it's
life right yeah you know there's there's
beauty in uh supernovas
there's there's beautiful
there's there's
beauty and meteors hitting the earth and
destroying life i mean yeah you can find
beauty and stuff
from death to life
yeah everything's beautiful
i'm so excited i think i'm most excited
about ace fest this year
because we got i just can't wait to see
what a [ __ ] show this is
so we also noticed that a lot of you
guys would want to come to the ace fest
by yourselves and you wouldn't be able
to come with a group of people it's a
family event who's going there by
themselves to [ __ ] bring home a kid
that ain't theirs
nobody said that also the two ticket
options
is hard for you to commit to so we're
gonna try our best
dude it's a fam who would go to that by
themselves genuinely
that's demented
that's sick if you're going to ace fest
alone yeah that is depressing
that is sad it's made for kids
and their families not saying that
we're going to feel bad now
somebody out there that actually would
do that want to come by themselves just
know that individual tickets may not
have the same benefits as the other
tickets we're trying to make it as fair
as possible guys
we want to make it as fair as we want
everyone to be happy like we're trying
really hard to make everyone happy yeah
um when we realized that so many people
were saying like hey like i just have
one person to go with or i i don't have
anyone to go with like i want to go
we realize okay like there is still oh
say good stay at home just not for you
leave your lonely ass at home don't be
around kids
you know
this
the two of them are so weird to me oh
yeah i never understand what's their
deal they're scammers
and then they're getting away with it
every damn [ __ ] year they do or every
six months
this boxing fiasco just happened and now
they're selling it sticking to their
next scam and people are buying it the
vip pass for this event allows you
access to all 2022 ace family events
including a boxing match that he has not
announced the opponent for
i'm sure that's going to panic yeah i'm
sure that's coming right up
who would ever take him up on that after
what just happened yeah like in one
universe yeah guys do they think they
can put a festival together
in three months i just don't understand
that
in three [ __ ] months
and then they're already like we want
everybody to be happy but it's really
difficult but
why do you even do this why are you
thinking that you can put together a
festival we got lots of inquiries from
the uh
from the uh
hospital for sexual deviants who want to
come with one person
so we're opening up to them and running
a special promotion
is there a hospital just for like p
words
it's got to be right it's that question
what what well because i was like
they'll run a special promotion for them
for one ticket
that's one of those questions where i
start to type to fact check and i'm like
why fact check it there's got to be
what is it
the ace family is running a special
promotion
you're saying there has to be a hospital
specifically for p words yeah what
why do you think that there has to be
there's a pr because it's like a prison
slash rehabilitation center for like
essay
work perhaps like okay an institution i
feel like there's got to be that
and i'm just i'm saying that maybe just
hospitalizing the right to sell tickets
they're trying to sell single rider
tickets that's a good place to
get some start
he has he'll build a special room for
with for them with one way class would
be nice
this place is called predators paradise
somebody said it's called prison
wait hold on predator
the thing that you're asking for is
called british oh you know what else is
called prayer predators paradise ace
fest
why is it called predator's paradise no
it's just the title of this article i'm
reading it now it's about a mental
hospital
uh wow
love said that kind of rehab usually
happens in prison
yeah yeah exactly that's what google
said
predators paradise aka ace fest
andrew hart uh here oh sorry wait what
happened
800 child m uh uh a child r words
housed at a state capital in the central
valley they were deemed too dangerous to
release when the prison sentence ended
oh yeah so they keep um
indefinitely
when the prison sentence ends
but they deserve to have a nice fun day
by themselves at ace fest so that's what
i'm saying that's 800
tickets you could sell that's a that's a
huge opportunity
that'd be awesome
the whole [ __ ]
the whole
the they all go on a day trip together
to ace fast
that's awful
my god
they have chaperones and [ __ ] they're
all in like white with chained
feet they're operating the ride just
cruising through his fest that's awesome
dude
fun time good wholesome family event
they're trying to make single tickets
more accessible
does that make sense
i think that's good
i think that's good of them to make
single tickets more accessible
you know
a lot of people that are willing to just
do that and since we can't sell too many
more tickets we'll be able to keep track
of individual tickets much easier than
selling group tickets because that's a
little more complicated one last thing
for the people who bought tickets to
answer some of your questions just know
when you guys come to ace fest your
parking is free your games are free your
rides are free and there is unlimited
you can play as many games as you want
for as long as you want god i can't wait
to see what these games are it's just
gonna be cornhole or some [ __ ] probably
yeah
yeah probably exactly that
you can ride as many rides as you want
for as long as you roll you can ride the
same ride
a hundred times if you can but i just
wanted to be clear some of you guys are
asking do you have to pay for this pay
for that no
you guys already bought the ticket you
just come to ace fest and enjoy
yourselves and have fun and hang out
with ace family so stay tuned for the
tickets opening back up and the
individual tickets coming because we are
going to speak to the event coordinators
and trying to figure this out because we
really want everyone to go
oh are they showing it no
that looks like
this is just their vlog
no no no i think this is the
i think this is where they're doing the
event parking lot
okay so this is
wait is that the wait that's the parking
lot this is where they're doing the
event damn this is where they have like
the biggest event in palmdale every year
they hold i want to say like 50 to like
100 000 people and so originally
katherine and i
what the economics of this does not make
any sense in a home depot park
well that would make sense thinking of
like only
having it
in a certain amount of section because
we didn't obviously know how well we
were going to do how many fan members
were going to come out so we only got
like a portion
of
what we needed and after the tickets
went on sale
we're like uh no yes we need more space
yeah so then we talked to
um
our partners in this and we asked them
basically oh god i can't wait they
probably haven't even booked it they
just went to a parking lot somewhere and
they're like oh
that's what we're gonna have it i just
can't wait to see what happens i'm so
excited in fact we're probably selling
more tickets to ace fest than they are
how many people are probably like damn i
gotta see this [ __ ] am i by myself you
know all the p words are coming all the
foot soldiers are coming it's gonna be a
hell of a crowd bro there's not gonna be
any kids
i can't wait
super exciting
but let's buy some merch
um let's see what kind of merch they
have
wristband
cloth blue cursive
what is that
great six dollar for a t-shirt
what the hell
you know what the [ __ ]
for a t-shirt
discounted from 25 bucks they're not
making any money online dude i don't
know what is that
but what is with the bracelet i'm
confused by that
does it even say ace family on it or
just some like stuff they got from it
says the ace family okay
[ __ ]
this is interesting
this is an idiot i'm gonna keep looking
at this
uh
lane a lanyard
what is a lanyard that's like where you
wear a badge no they hold your keys i
mean yeah
anything like that
who's buying that
children that has kissed yeah kids okay
yes okay i don't know
evidently no one based off of the
discounts they're offering this is the
weirdest collection of merch i've ever
seen
what the f
lanyards bracelets and six dollar
t-shirts
the ace family check out that wait did
it did i see that that was a poncho you
got an east family poncho oh for real
all right poncho style last item last
item on the list that's i thought it was
a bat that was a tote bag poncho style
pink that's a [ __ ] poncho i thought
it was a tote bag dude what poncho style
ace fam
towel poncho style oh it's a towel got
it wait can you wear it though i guess
yeah okay yeah
with the hood in the pocket no it says
adult size oh
i've seen those
it's very strange all sales are final no
exchange or refunds my man
my man always on his [ __ ]
do you not have to offer refunds
no in america no you don't
pretty sweet huh
yeah seems nice i don't think so anyway
i'm pretty sure
there's lots of websites there's a lot
of brands that are done yeah they do
final sale surprising like
that's crazy teddy fresh does we have
excellent service we got refunds you can
write an email and be like yo ethan's a
piece of [ __ ] i don't like him he'll be
like cool no problem
refunded no questions asked
oh i love ace family they're just such
[ __ ] scum
i love it
i [ __ ] love it
so now that we've gotten a little bit
through this episode can we get to a
better title please because i don't like
the title
what would you like to call it
tim pool [ __ ] for brains
[Music]
dan don't
don't even pretend
the thing is [ __ ] for brains is a funny
insult but with him with the top half of
his head being open he actually could
have someone could [ __ ] in his head and
he would have [ __ ] for brains that would
be pretty insensitive then so i guess we
should off topic yeah zach you are
chewing so loud that was that noise yes
i thought it was a leak wait are you
chewing it to the mic zach no he's
closed okay what are you chewing gum
okay
nope it don't
sounds like bother
camel's behind me
you start talking to my mic
oh my god wait here's one of the single
riders uh
uh this is
we just got some intel
james is going by himself
right yeah
he's dripped out that was actually the
comment that was the person who left the
comment was like yo can i buy a ticket
for myself was james charles
and in the role of a lifetime in the
role of a lifetime seeing a lot of calls
for beans on toast title uh you guys
want that beans on toasty trying to
[ __ ] make beans on toast and uh a
post-apocalyptic slop special
[Laughter]
all right so you guys don't want people
to watch my video you're saying
you're trying to destroy my career in
other words
well we just uh let's just let's do the
app ethan ethan has a heart attack live
on air right
that'll get close ethan's anus prolapse
is live yeah live on air
maybe we finish the app and then we can
decide that's what i'm saying
and then everyone can vote we can do
that
so kim kardashian threatens to destroy
roblox
yeah johnny depp first
let's do we have the story prompt too
that was fun maybe we should do that eh
let's do the kim thing because uh we we
have a little edit for that even so
so kim kardashian
i don't even know if i can show this
clip because it's from the keep up with
kardashians and you know they don't
[ __ ] let anything go
get your [ __ ] her son it was a clip
from keeping up with the kardashians her
how was her son like seven eight
something
uh six younger yeah younger six so he
was trying keeping up with he was
playing roblox
and i guess in roblox there was some
clip of her
sex tape it was just i don't think it
was even a clip of it but it was a
reference to it uh it was like an ad it
was an ad in the game like a funny ad
well roblox is like minecraft i think in
that it's all player driven content
right so so somebody else made it yeah
in the game yeah the developers have
nothing to do with that it's like ryan
cavanaugh going to our reddit page and
being like
he's doing everything you know it's kind
of an open platform
so she's threatening to sue uh roblox
after the game claiming to offer an
unreleased sex tape
of hers and her son found it
let's see
kim kardashian threatened to sue roblox
uh roblox the gaming player yada yada
i have all the time all the money and
all the resources to burn them to the
[ __ ] ground i don't think even her
she's a i don't think she can touch
roblox that's like a jug or not roblox
is definitely a juggernaut like i'm
sorry i'm sorry but you need to check
yourself because you're up it doesn't
sound like something you can sue over
no isn't she studying the law
in 20 questions in 2021 uh
in the year 2021 the the game roblox
revenue was just shy of two billion
dollars wow
so there you go there's the ego um lady
you actually are not you have nothing on
roblox they will destroy you
okay
21 billion market cap on the company
holy [ __ ] yeah
they're a juggernaut i've never played
roblox have any you guys uh
i watched quite a bit of it yesterday
because there was doing uh we did some
investigative journalism on this whole
controversy my one of my nieces is very
sweet she won't talk to me unless i play
roblox with her so that's the only way
she'll
it seems fun i mean it's kind of like a
minecrafty type of thing right yeah i
don't know how i'm doing uh yes it's
similar to minecraft in that it it's
very customizable uh
and you can sort of
people make games within games like when
cam was playing with it the other day he
was just playing like fortnight somebody
just like recreated fortnite in roblox
yeah so i feel like it's a lot like
minecraft which
it's really just about the ingenuity of
the users that make it fun yeah
the characters look like lego men and it
has kind of like a lego aesthetic
roblox has since banned the developer
of the game and denied its platform ever
featured the s tape
yeah well i mean while i agree her it's
messed up her son saw that but like
didn't she i mean
she's kind of
i mean it's obviously inevitable no
i mean when you become famous really for
doing that everything is on the internet
that's kind of the price you pay now
yeah
no it was inevitable i just uh it sucks
that it happened so young you know well
of course it was going i think the kid
didn't actually understand uh what they
were uh
looking at she was just upset that they
could have potentially come across it
but
yeah i mean uh you know i didn't listen
and do kind of i feel bad and you know
it's part of these kids are going to
find out
and they're going to find out young
because you know
that's just the way the world is our
life now
yeah i made a quick google and
apparently you can set up like parental
control on roblox too so
yeah
if she really wanted to i think i think
that they're saying that uh some people
have found ways around
the uh filters and i think that's why
she's saying that roblox should get in
trouble
from what i'm reading
i just love that quote i mean she's so
delusional
i have all the time all the money and
all the resources to burn them to the
ground
it seems like nobody wants to work these
days look it she put it out knowingly
right the s tape that was like a whole
plan thing i don't know anything i think
it was just a rumor i don't think it was
oh really did the mom have something to
do with it there was also another rumor
profited big time from that wait i
thought that was like their whole thing
that they put it out her and ray j
ray i think ray j
put it out
and then kim got a piece of it
so there
she did agree to put it out i believe
okay well regardless
so
you guys want to do your thing
it was far from the game's first
controversy roblox was sued for 200
million last year
over unauthorized song use
you what do you guys got you want to
play it
oh there's a there's a video uh it's in
the dark yeah cameron's correspondence
here all right so we are in the game
reporting
live we are going all places virtual or
or or uh
unvirtual
concrete but here we are
those who make peaceful revolution
impossible will make violent revolution
inevitable
john f
kennedy there is a revolutionary fire
that lights the hearts of roblox
everywhere
users are gathering in mass to protest
kim kardashian's recent latitude threats
against the popular video game
in no relation to gamestop marketing
campaigns the chant power to the player
is being spammed in chat rooms
everywhere across multiple game levels
this developer even created a kim
kardashian monster to search and destroy
protesters bloxblood paints the
pixelated streets and tensions continue
to rise i visited a more subtle level
where jesus christ himself showed up in
support of the game
finally i paid a visit to the kardashian
family themselves but it seems like this
level was in need of updates
it is friday baby
ultimately they could not be reached for
comment so it was time to call it a day
[Applause]
yo those game versions look sick
so are those are those good job cam
virtual reporting so are those real
places in the game the kim [ __ ] yeah i
mean right now if any foot soldiers are
out there that have roadblocks i'm
currently in the kardashian mansion
level but yeah there's there's a few
protests going on
uh when you type in kim kardashian on
the search yeah they should stand up for
the rights that's their game
roblox is their home
a lot of chad is saying that kim uh did
not give consent for that tape to come
out
um oh i'm not sure the real story but
that's what chad is saying right now so
okay well then then then i do feel
worse then i do feel bad for her in that
case
but i'm curious did she ever try to stop
the circulation did she actually get
money
she sued to prevent it from being
released so how can you guys talk about
how they're like these mastermind
marketers and then say that was
unintentional
was denying their master marketers i
mean we weren't specifically referring
to the sex tape but like
you said i know but you go oh she didn't
consul consent
but then when i say she says something
dumb and everyone
calls me a [ __ ] psycho for thinking
that it wasn't planned it's a statement
versus sex tape
i mean that's her son right now i mean
the consequences i feel like are a lot
more intense sure for for her son but
don't you okay whatever i don't i don't
need to get all these [ __ ] weirdo kim
kardashian people don't abuse me again
ethan i'm not i'm not asking i got
nothing to do with you
i got nothing to do with you
wow
this is just this just in
uh i'm in roblox right now
and the word kardashian is censored
you can't even see i can't even say
kardashian anymore really wow
what
that's a bad word but surely that's just
going to make people want to type it out
that's the thing this whole thing this
whole thing is a uh
what's the streisand effect we're
witnessing it in real time
because yeah she
they put it in their show
which
got everybody talking about it and now
it's a meme and roblox is just overrun
with kim kardashian's stuff
um which is just gonna exacerbate the
whole thing
yeah i mean i understand her being upset
about it but um
you know if
they didn't want uh
this kind of attention on the thing
which is gonna inevitably wind up with
her kids finding out about it uh
probably shouldn't have put it in the
show and that was probably a bad call
because
now it's now it's a meme and now
you've got [ __ ]
what we just saw we got whole rooms of
roblox dedicated roblox v kardashians
war of the century yeah
okay well you know what
sucks but at the end of the day i just
can't find it in my heart to care that
much about whatever the [ __ ] you're
dealing with sorry
is that too callous the quote is
just [ __ ] about ray j and his manager
holy [ __ ] um i mean there's a bunch of
articles about this attributing that
quote to her threatening roblox so
people are saying that write a letter to
uh the publication wait does she saying
that quote is not real
just somebody in the chat is saying that
but i god people care so much about her
it's like i can't even say [ __ ] without
people i know losing my mind and she is
i [ __ ] hate her so
it's like not that that i think that
stuff like this should happen to her but
like just i hate the [ __ ] kardashians
so i just think they're the most vapid
people in the world so
it's hard to uh it's hard to give a [ __ ]
i don't care what am i supposed to care
there's people dying every day i'm
supposed to care about kim kardashian
i'm supposed to care about her feelings
there's [ __ ] do you know what i'm
saying
like i only have so much bandwidth to
have for sympathy
sorry kim kardashian is not on my
[ __ ] list
just saying just saying
you know
saying
just saying
uh well okay
um
you guys want to do the discussion
prompt
you can put
this off for a long ass time
basically we have a discussion prompt
okay let's do a poll should i care about
kim kardashian's feelings yes or no
should i should i set aside bandwidth
and my limited spectrum of sympathy
amy says yes
yes to caring about cancer yeah ab is a
very soft spot in his heart for that i
didn't
i think the reason people get worked up
is they're superimposing themselves like
what if i had to deal with this with my
kid and that's why they get worked up i
can't hear you
you're mike coming in quiet
uh i was saying that i think people
are passionate not because of kim as a
figure or character but just they're
superimposing themselves
onto that situation like what what would
i go through if that happened to me yeah
you know in an x of mine so i think
that's why people are sure and i have
involved okay sympathy for that you know
aspect of it like yeah obviously you
don't want your kids seeing your sex
tape that's horrible well i was actually
under the impression that she was
put it out but i don't think so that
changes it that's what i think it just
yeah from what i just briefly read it
showed her crying face and when you
clicked on it it said something like
watch her new sex yeah he didn't
actually it was like an exactly and it's
like yeah it's just a joke the fact that
she had a sex tip is just something that
her kids will eventually find out and i
guess this was how this kid found out
you know yeah they're faint they're
famous and
it's just gonna happen it's unfortunate
but
that's the reality like with the
internet it's just
they're going to find out
wait till they find out she's the one
that killed harambe
wow
that's really getting disturbed uh what
is the poll should i care about the
cartage should i have the bandwidth in
my delicate spectrum of sympathy okay
that might be too many characters
but but but in truth i thought she put
out the sex tape so it does make me feel
worse a little bit worse for her but at
the end of the day why doesn't why
doesn't kendall just give her a [ __ ]
pepsi and tell her oh true
that's not really her sister's the pepsi
girl just [ __ ] deal with your [ __ ]
whatever cancel the poll yeah let's just
move on all right our discussion prompt
for the day
is infamous stories
your family always tell
you know within every family there's
specific lore
things that went down within your family
that everyone always talks about
i have one
i'll tell it
so within my family
there's a certain phrase after my
brother sean
when someone brutally spoils a movie
and it's called shauning a movie
and my brother was notorious for this he
he
i he just would
unintentionally just spoil the ending of
movies and it has happened so many times
the best example when this uh
phrase was born
now you guys remember the hype around
the
sixth sense i can't remember if it's i
always remember six cents
there's really five other senses
smell
taste
vision hearing
feeling okay yeah
that seems like a lot maybe fact check
that
i know
there's a lot to handle five senses
[Laughter]
but do you mean a lot to handle it's a
lot of senses five of them
oh that's a
that's an all-timer right there
there's really five different senses it
just seems like a lot i thought you were
saying it's not enough
no no for christ's sake the sixth one is
seeing dead people how much more
do you need
i'm overwhelmed
sensory overload so anyway the sixth
sense
was out and it was like super hyped that
movie was a cultural phenomenon yeah it
was a great movie by the way i love that
movie
and it has this incredible twist ending
you're going to forgive me for spoiling
it for you now it's been about 20 years
so i think the ship has sailed but if
you don't want to be spoiled in the
sixth sense i guess you don't want to be
spoiled
for a few minutes close your eyes
uh but like it had in my opinion one of
the best twist endings ever it was like
oh [ __ ] my boy
and if you find out the ending it
basically ruins the whole movie because
the whole movie is informed by
your suspense of not knowing what's
going on and if you get the ending
spoiled it ruins the whole [ __ ] movie
um
so
i go out to see this movie with my
brother who's he's two and a half years
old with me and he had already seen it
and he loved it and so we went to go see
it together
and there's this one scene
where
[Music]
it was so stupid uh
bruce willis and the kid
were on a swing
and my brother leans over to me who's
already seen the movie this is halfway
through the movie and he goes hey
you notice how um
bruce willis doesn't have a shadow
now
what was so stupid about it is because i
immediately understood that he had
spoiled the movie i said oh he's dead my
brother just spoiled it
but what was so stupid is that he did
have a shadow there was a shadow there
it wasn't even a good observation
so he spoiled it for me halfway through
the movie
with that dumb comment like why
but that's not where the story ends
so when we're home
we go home
and my dad's in the kitchen
and i'm like he was like how's the movie
whatever i was like it's shawn ruined
the [ __ ] movie for me midway through
he's turns to me and tells me literally
the ending
and then my brother goes in front of my
dad who's really excited to see this
movie too he goes i never told you he
was dead oh nice and then my dad's like
you just spoiled the [ __ ] movie for
me
and that's where the phrase shauning the
movie was born he spoiled it for both of
us
separately
incredible skill
of spoiling the movie so there you go if
it happens in your life you can always
say
shawnd the movie that's pretty
it apologies to all other seans that
have to bear that cross but
there you have it
all right who wants to go next
anybody
i guess i can go go ahead dan
yeah so an infamous one in our family is
um
actually it's funny we're doing this
today because just on wednesday's
episode when you were grilling me uh
like a cop with that stash
uh
we talked about um how my parents worked
in animation and everything i mentioned
that they worked on the muppet babies so
when i was just a little baby i think i
was only like three months old
um
my
dad got some gig that required him to
fly out to hawaii for a couple weeks
and so
my mom dad and little three-month-old
danny went out to uh maui for a few
weeks
and while he was there
they had already
been working for uh marvel animation
for a little bit but they had just
recently started
working as writers on the show it was
like a big break for them it was a big
deal for them at the time
and
a new season was happening
and last minute
the
all the suits decided that they needed
to be there for this meeting the only
problem is the meeting was in toronto
so my dad hops on a plane and flies out
to toronto uh with the family like you
know that that night
well so he was in maui it happened to be
winter time in toronto
uh so it's like below zero
and my dad shows up
with nothing but like hawaii clothes
shorts hawaiian shirt and sandals and
they have this meeting at like seven in
the morning it was super jet like so we
had no time
no time at all to
get new clothes or business attire or
anything so it's at this like fancy
hotel they have like a conference room
and it's all the suits he walks in he's
like long
table with like 30 guys and suits and
jim henson is there who he had never met
before but the man himself the legend
jim henson is at this meeting
my dad walks in
wearing the shorts and sandals and
everything he walks and i guess i guess
because he was jet lagged or something
he sits down on on a seat and tips back
and immediately tips back too far oh it
falls over backwards
and he like kind of sheepishly gets up
and he's like oh anything for a laugh
and like everybody's just like who the
[ __ ] is this guy
but here's the thing
apparently
jim henson thought that was hilarious of
course and he took a looking to my dad
and my dad always said he was he was
one of the sweetest coolest people he'd
ever known
um and uh
yeah he
i mean they still gave him the gig after
that so i guess it didn't kill it
but yes this uh this this story is
infamous in our family of my doofus ass
dad flipping over backwards in a
hawaiian shirt in the dead of winter
dude you know jim henson loved that
though your dad cruising in and
blistering cold in a hawaiian shirt
that's awesome dude
that's epic story yeah i love that for
him love that for him
who's your dad what's your dad's name
uh you don't want to say you don't have
to say i guess it doesn't his name's
larry larry
and your dad's gary larry and gary
anyone else have a dad name that rhymes
with that
larry gary and terry
our dads would probably get along pretty
well my animal spirit dad larry david so
i can write very larry and gary yes i
feel like i can relate
um do you think dave would be a good dad
or you [ __ ] you up
he would [ __ ] you up yeah yeah but still
yeah no i know he's a dad i mean is his
are his kids he has a daughter they
actually seem pretty legit they seem
nice yeah okay good family good probably
fine good family
um my story is not like funny or
anything i wasn't sure what angle we're
going but
just i guess like
i thought something that's like a lore
in the family
so in our family it's the fact that my
dad built the house that
we live in or
i mean i don't no longer live there but
that's where i live my whole life
um
so
i don't have much to say about it but i
have pictures
well that he built it he
he when they were i don't know he was
like 30 something and he uh
he made
money for himself from
like he was working in um
what do you call it when you built the
stones for oh he was a he was a
masonry masonry is that what it's called
yeah he built he built he did stone
marble yeah marble work yep so you would
work with marble and um
he
did it on his own independently and
saved money
and then eventually he bought a piece of
land
and
he
built the house and then
here it is
so when you say he built it he he
he knew a lot of people like
somebody who will lay the floors or
somebody that will build the wall or
paint you know but he kind of like put
the whole thing together
and he was there every day
and this house looks epic it's very nice
especially for israel but yeah it's
really nice like three stories
do you know how long it took of mila
about like a year from what i've heard a
little bit faster than lena's dead
a year dana's dad is still building it's
been 25 years 25 years but it's like a
scarface like mansion overseas in
lebanon 25 years
was he building a cathedral it might as
well be it's massive just slowly over
the summers
your dad looks badass though
he's like i built this [ __ ] yeah look at
that that's always kind of like the vibe
like yeah what you're sitting in the
house that i built that's even worse
it's not like i own this house yeah this
is my house i built this house you'll
wear [ __ ] shoes when you come here
not sandals right all right
i'm sorry do you say your family still
lives there now yeah that's awesome
that's really cool
i thought it was kind of cool
but is there any funny stories about how
like the house was kind of [ __ ] up
because he built it because i feel like
you told me that
uh
no
oh no
can you say the pipes are all [ __ ] up
and [ __ ] because you built it well no no
no it's what
over time
when he was younger he used to do
everything like when he built the house
you'll get everything the most expensive
materials
put in all the effort
i don't know what happened over time as
he was getting older but he just was not
properly taken care of the house okay so
that's what
[Music]
eventually now when my after i passed
away and my mom is kind of left with the
house she had to do a lot of work too
to fix things
but that's different
shout out to yochanon
who built a whole damn house
what a man
they don't make men like they used to
huh folks
what are we going to do about this
what we would be without joking on
he built a whole damn house himself
isn't it crazy though like today you
could never do that
he wasn't like rich you know he worked
he said right he was like he was
of
assaulted
yeah a hardworking person but yeah that
is crazy you're right allison my uh
girlfriend her dad is a lot like your
dad
and they live back in idaho and they
have a gorgeous huge house and yeah he
straight up built the entire thing
himself i guess you can if you live
somewhere like idaho but even
like this is 1984 i mean i wasn't even
born yet yeah but like even in idaho i
wonder i guess you could if you go to a
remote area you could probably yeah
they're fairly remote they're they're
out in the prairie
on the prairie
i guess you can still it just depends
where you live it's funny when your dad
built that house alone was probably
considered a remote now it's part of
like the central area it's expensive now
is that true do you think
it's definitely
way more expensive nowadays yeah back
then yeah
well there you have it
exactly your stories about your dads
let's hear about your debt exactly
no stories about my dad's penis but um
i i was going to share the story that my
family always talks about well
my friend i was thinking what what i
could tell and i really
nothing came to mind but whenever my
best friend comes to dinner we always
tell this story and that's of when him
and i got arrested
okay
um which i feel like he does to piss my
dad off which is pretty funny to be
honest because they have a good
relationship but he likes to get his get
but uh yeah well i i was i guess
detained would be the
the proper term
we uh
we went
to my other buddies went up to a missile
silo abandoned in uh
chatsworth
and it's
it's abandoned they used to hold bombs
there and nukes there for world war two
and
things crazy it's creepy's all [ __ ] and
the only way you can get up there is um
going up a road that's locked
so there was one day where we decided to
find a back way up
and we did took us about an hour to get
up there we drove my buddy's truck
and um we got up there and explored and
you can actually go in the missile silo
and
we put on gloves we go down we get
flashlights and it's creepy's all [ __ ]
there's like graffiti you can look it up
it's called like la-88
and um
i'm about to go silo and i see an
unmarked
police car pull up
and it was la's swat
and this guy gets out of the car and he
comes out gun blazing and he's like what
the [ __ ] are you doing up here don't you
know we do helicopter target practice i
was doing a sweep of the area for one
last time
and um
that's the story he put us in
so that's not the
final part of the story but he puts us
in
cuffs
and
he's like do you know how much [ __ ]
trouble you're in and i was so scared
what my dad was going to say
you're the joker i belong in this
assignment
was there no warnings or anything how
did you get there i mean it was our gate
a fence
we found a back trail
back trail did you did you tell them yo
there's a backdrop you'll need to mark
that [ __ ] no no no
we just did it we just went for it it
took us about an hour to get up there
and so why did you guys go there yeah
why'd you go up there just because we
were stupid
but did you hear there was something
there like whoa what is the
yeah we we always knew there was a
missile silo up there
sorry muted um you're talking about the
the missile silo up at in the valley in
chatsworth yeah i snuck into that too
yeah okay i didn't get arrested though
yeah so
you went to the bathroom but they were
doing helicopter target practice
and they were doing uh the final sweep
so
the guy puts us in cuffs
and he's like do you know how much
[ __ ] trouble you're in this
trespassing blah blah blah
and um
he's like you know what you caught me on
a good day i'm gonna get you i'm gonna
give you
10 seconds to get the [ __ ] out of here
so we run to my buddy's truck do a full
10 seconds pick it run did he shoot at
you no no thank god but he was [ __ ]
putting his hand on the holster
and um
we went down the way
of the the paved road rather than the
the uh the
dirt road we took to get up there
and um
as we're coming down the road
we just see about like 10 lapd swat just
holding these [ __ ] guns and we start
hearing helicopters and [ __ ]
and so yeah that's my story they fire on
you no did they stare at you they were
like you guys are [ __ ] idiots yeah
so wait did you go during the night or
something dan because it seems like if
they went in the middle of the night yes
and you went in the middle of the day
zach yeah yeah that was probably that
was probably your first mistake
but night would have been [ __ ] creepy
as [ __ ] it was it was very creepy yeah
so were your parents pissed
yeah
i don't know what they could have done i
mean
the force of the worst kind of happened
but yeah we always tell that story
whenever my buddy comes over for dinner
interesting
the silo story yeah missile silo
be careful out there
you think they would have used you for
target practice dude [ __ ] if they
started firing we'd have been so [ __ ]
oh my god
because they were doing a helicopter
target practice yeah i remember when
when i went uh there were empty shells
like all over the place oh yeah
covered
yeah it was creepy
yeah so you think they would have seen
two guys down there and they're just
like open fire
i don't know if they would have seen us
that was the thing though
the guy was doing a final sweep so he
kind of saved our life in a way
was there bullet holes and is that thing
all shot up to silo well the silo's in
the ground yeah it's like an underground
facility but there's like uh abandoned
buses up there and um
there's like other things
that are just disheveled and [ __ ]
it was the weirdest thing because did
you go down into the silo dude yeah yeah
yeah yeah was there arabic writing all
over the walls i don't remember arabic i
remember a [ __ ] ton of graffiti though
there was arabic writing all over the
walls and my assumption was that they
were using it for like counter terrorism
training simulation or something it was
like very weird but
honestly i don't know
maybe look at you
maybe you know anything about that you
know anything maybe no thoughts
maybe thoughts um ian go ahead
um
thank you zach by the way
uh
something that pops into my head this is
a quick one it's not some big long story
but i remember when i was really young
um
i was visiting my family
over in england sorry to keep bringing
it up but uh
uh we went to the tower of london it's
like a place um where they keep the
crown jewels and
lots of um museum stuff
and
outside in the courtyard is like where
they would
behead people um that's where they
beheaded uh
king henry viii's wife
um
two of them actually
right
and
it's like it's kind of a serious place
you know and we were walking around
we're standing in front of where they
would behead people very intense i was
very young too and we were sitting there
like this is where they would kill
people that's pretty intense
and there was a guy
in front of us
and as we were kind of sitting there
sort of taking in this
weird energy
this guy like
maybe he had too many beans on toast or
something
but this guy let out like the the
nastiest loudest
shart i've ever heard like in my entire
life i've never heard one like this
and it was dead quiet there was no one
there in this courtyard except us
this like guillotine zone and this guy
yeah it was like that but like oh it
kind of echoed yeah yeah except even
worse
and uh
it was just a moment of silence and we
were standing behind him and he was like
facing back
and he kind of went like
are you guys staring at him in the eyes
yeah he locked us he kind of went like
you smile or laugh no
and then he immediately went in the mic
and then he ran off he just he ran yeah
he wrote god oh maybe he did [ __ ]
himself
i'm pretty sure he shoot his pants wow
the power of the of the guillotine in
front of him
and he just guillotined his gym shorts
yeah
that's awesome man i don't know his
[ __ ] got possessed by one of those
queen
yeah yeah and uh that just that that
lives on i just that guy i've never seen
someone so scared
that face
haunts me
you know i have a similar story when i
it was the day of my bar mitzvah
i was doing my whole ceremony i think i
just finished
i was feeling good i was feeling happy
sean balog was with me in the bathroom
we both had to go bathroom
we were at the urinals peeing and just
one solitary old dude comes in the empty
bathroom
and he's taking a piss and he rips the
loudest gnarliest fart
and you know some things just stick with
you and it was so casual usually if you
fart you look over you don't rip ass
like that around other people you are
more sly about it but he's old i was
like okay you're all you don't care
right it's interesting
i'm more like that these days because i
didn't understand it at the time but if
i'm at the urinal i don't care who's
around me i'm gonna [ __ ] rip the
thought
sure yeah i'll do it yeah if not then if
not now then when
and i feel like it's kind of interesting
my evolution
it's the bathroom if you're you going
you're pissing it's time to rip ass i'm
not gonna be all top secret about it
this is where we do these things you're
telling me you could be at like an event
or something
and there's a bunch of people in the
bathroom and you gotta fart before you
pee you'll just literally push out to
make it loud
stop i swear to god i will you take
pride in it i started doing that why
because it's more to me it's more
satisfying when it
comes out like that
why so i don't like to subtly fart
sometimes you get stuck you have to be
satisfying sometimes you get stuck
sometimes you need to force you
sometimes you need to fart before you
pee i get it no when you're at the
urinal standing a pig
it's time it's a fart time
it's a fart time baby it's part time
baby
these stories do remind me one other
story
that's kind of like family lore is that
uh
one time there was uh when i was a kid
there was like some kind of war going on
and um
the sirens were going off and we had to
go to the
we had a shelter like in the basement
we had to all go to the shelter and put
on this like mask and stuff and i was on
the party i was going poop
and the siren was going on and
everyone's running downstairs and it's
like oh my god i just remembered being
on the on the toilet siren and
everybody's like come on
hussein was threatening to like
chemical warfare on israel yeah
and so what did you do did you were you
choosing between i was like hold on hold
on i i was a kid i barely remember it
it's just like stuck in my memory
sitting on the toilet and like having to
go
you don't really remember it it's just
kind of told to you no i remember being
on the toilet and the siren going and
everybody's like come on we gotta go
downstairs so did you pinch it off did
you wipe
i that like i don't remember those
details no i don't know what i think i
finished pooping you did the whole thing
you wiped you flushed you washed your
hands my mom was probably helping me i
was a kid oh you were really young yeah
you have a similar memory during the
northridge earthquake that will rocked
la
i don't i don't know if this ever
happened to you dan but taking a [ __ ]
during one of those big after sharks was
after
shots
it was so crazy it became an uh
that may have happened i i don't
specifically remember getting caught on
so i've been on the [ __ ] during a
fairly large after shock
and the water's just like
oh no
it's great
i mean here
pull up a video of a toilet
during an earthquake you could see it's
just
i don't know if i've ever seen that it's
a gnarly starter here that's a good
point
i've never seen that before i bet i was
on there
i was on the [ __ ] during a large
aftershock and it was just like a wave
pool in there man with full of turds
uh unfortunately
not seeing
many and the whole history of the world
there's no damn video of a toyota caught
that how about a bathtub or a swimming
pool
show a swimming pool during oh yeah
that'll give you an idea
i can visualize that
the toilet like in fact we got a whole
compilation so imagine this is the
toilet with [ __ ] and these people are
pieces of [ __ ]
there you go
whoa that's crazy oh yeah so that's what
the toilet was like but it's sloshing on
the sides
dude that's so scary holy [ __ ] this is
terrifying that is actually pretty wild
yeah it doesn't look like they're very
strong swimmers either oh my god someone
helped that pork chop okay enough yeah
anyway those are my shits
splashing at my [ __ ]
i did see some people saying can you
guys show a video where like people are
just drowning
there's like fun videos i didn't embed
it very well you have to watch people
drown swimming pool during earthquake
compilation
they're fine
your story about you farting freely um
a lot of people are pointing this out it
does seem to confirm
uh this is not real
i don't know
this is the security footage apparently
of me and denny's by myself people have
absolutely framed me
crazy footage you're just farting your
ass off that looks photoshopped that
looks edited
[Music]
it's pretty authentic to me would you
rip in the denny's
well apparently no no
why not
mean i wouldn't rip loud if i was in a
restaurant i would fart but not loud
well how can
how many years until you uh
i don't think i'll ever do that no
you'll get there
it depends how loud it is
in the restaurant
like if if theodor or el are next to me
i would like them to hear it
of course but i don't want the people
next to us in the booth next to us it's
part of the joy of sharing
theodor loves when i fart by the way he
[ __ ] loves it no he does not thinks
it's so funny
i go you're brainwashing him to think
that it's fine i go theodore hold on i
have something really important to tell
you and he always looks at me
super expect it and then i fart and it
goes grubs
but i get them every time it's awesome
every time theodore hold on you want to
know something really interesting
every time it works it's awesome
poor boy he wants to learn something new
when he does he does like yes teach me
something theodore hold on did you hear
that i go do you hear that theodore
every time it works
so good it's so good
um abe did you tell a story no i didn't
not yet good so i was having trouble
coming up with one um so i thought i'd
just explain like some family lore you
talking about a family meme
thank you thank you zach
uh
i've explained on the show before that
i come from like a really religious
family not my parents but like my aunts
and uncles especially my aunts my
grandmother
and i kind of [ __ ] up my cousins
because they were told they're going to
hell for everything so they sort of
rebelled as they got older
um
so i put together just like a minute
video showing
uh
showing this meme they act like they
want to punch my aunt in the face when
they see her like they see red their mom
their mom oh see if they're going to a
blind rage they never do and she ends up
laughing but wait i got to see this
let me see this [ __ ]
roll it
is it this one yeah oh i can click it i
got it okay
so these are my cousins tim and brandon
we know tim of course
this was lena's first time meeting him
okay we paused for context thanks for
watching
i've already i made this right before
the show by the way i've already
explained this context about how they
act like they're gonna hit their mom
because of all the years of uh
of being tortured told they're going to
hell so they act like they hate her when
they see her but okay it's just a meme
am i muted is that why yeah
does it
oh yeah this is my cousin brendan act
like he's gonna throw his mom off the
roof
this is my this is him acting like he's
gonna kill my aunt selma
oh my god
wait is that tim he's so skinny though
yeah
this uh
he's actually gonna kill my aunt but
then lina comes out when he stops
because he hides
i walked in i'm gonna start doing that
to my mom wow
my grandmother was like really bad
telling us we're gonna go to hell for
everything so then me and my cousins
just started to act crazy and just do
random ass [ __ ] because she doesn't
understand english so they would just
make noises and stuff
so yeah this is
how it was with my grandma if you
unpause it
i had to blur her because she's not
wearing a scarf
there was a longer cut with tim messing
with my grandma but i took that out
because
tim may be a little too far
you took it too far
with nana
then we're just like tim would just like
she'd just be like dozing off and tim
would just like scream
the [ __ ] i guess she's getting revenge i
mean i mean we don't condone that me and
me
me and his younger brother the one that
was doing the doctor strange and the
forced lightning was we're more playful
tim's a little out there
um i'm gonna start doing that to my to
my mom and put her headlock
yeah tim used to go to my grandmother
she as she got older started getting a
little bit more senile and
he thought it was so funny to give her
like a big butcher knife and tell her
stay protected and she like put it under
the bed
and she said give her a big butcher
knife and tell her what stay protected
that's insane or he like start chanting
like some lebanese like political like
chance and get her hyped up she's
thinking she's like back in the war
that's wow that's kind of [ __ ] nuts
dude i'm surprised that she goes along
with it she said he said she's senile
or well the one she would yeah
that sounds like elder abuse she would
laugh i mean she she loved him she would
always she liked him the most it was
very interesting okay
so elder abuse or no she's dead
right well just kidding but uh clearly
yes if it wasn't no but that's what you
love that's why i took up tim's tim's
part because i was like people may
interpret that the wrong way
we love cousin tim
um
i'm gonna do that to my mom i'll give
her a butcher knife put her in a
headlock
you start telling we're being baited
the chat saying abs tell the uh
pissy story
but what
my cousins were so [ __ ] bad
that
they started calling their mom the p
word
there because she was like super
religious and they were so [ __ ] bad
that they were like they called the word
or p word the p word which p like
but but they said with an accent they
call it pissy what's that piss they used
to say like that like they were like oh
like that they were not
it's so [ __ ] i can't like i can't
explain in a short amount of time so i'm
just not because it sounds so [ __ ]
bad it is so [ __ ] bad but
but like it got to the point where like
like they would be like i love you pissy
and they were and she would like hug him
like oh i love you too like you just
look it's just like a nickname like
that's crazy yeah
it's wild
it's wild and she couldn't tell any of
the other adults because like she was
embarrassed to say like oh my kids are
this [ __ ] up and i was young and i was
like i don't want to snitch on my
cousins
and yeah it was just a circus in that
house
that's wild who's malcolm in the middle
uh
real life
nice there you have it
love you got a story
i love our camp uh i didn't really but
zack didn't inspire me he kind of
unlocked a childhood memory
if i should tell that maybe
with the whole like police chase and
stuff like that
uh
so this requires a link i have a google
drive link or a google maps got it uh so
make sure that it doesn't show anything
doxy on your end
it's just a google maps right yeah okay
exactly all right so
if you show that yellow house right
there i'm just looking around it's a
nice neighborhood beautiful yeah it's
all right yeah
but anyway here's a yellow house so that
house is clearly cursed right it looks
[ __ ] yeah yeah it looks really first
and it's like one off in the whole
neighborhood there's this one creepy ass
house
and this is right by my school by the
way so
every time me and my friends walked home
to do whatever we
used to hang out every time after school
we walked past this building every day
and we never saw anyone but there was a
rumor that the drapes on the upstairs
level moved sometimes
so me and my friends like just hunkered
down and sat outside this house for
maybe two hours
and just looked at it and there was this
in sweden because
there's a lot of snow
they put like
small gravel super tiny gravel on the
ground so we took this small gravel and
just like threw like threw them at the
window every now and then
super dumb yeah i admit
uh but maybe after one hour of doing
that just randomly throwing a small rock
on the window they come out there come
out this like slender
super tall old man
with like super long creepy hair
and just started chasing us you got
slenderman dude you literally got
literally slenderman did you not think
that anyone actually lived there
no no one did no even like the adults
who
i'll get to it later in the video but or
in the explanation uh like even adult
people thought it wasn't that weird that
we did because there was no one living
there everyone was under that impression
and
yeah so he came out he ran through that
creepy as gate as you can see
on the google maps thing and if you look
to the left uh
in google maps
get the other way across the street
no so the other way
and follow this road straight down
so the other way other way
so
at the bottom of this street
if you go straight down
yeah keep going keep going
uh keep going uh and to the right up
here that's a
cemetery and one of my friend got split
off my me and my friends ran left here
one of my friends who was at the end ran
straight uh so straight ahead into the
cemetery and got chased by this old man
into the cemetery
yeah so so we later we were all like
just running like super scared super
much adrenaline and we realized where
the [ __ ] is tim
tim is gone we where's tim and we like
ran back and looked for him and we like
sat like
walked people through people's yards and
we noticed that tim was at the [ __ ]
cursed house
turns out he had been pulled back by
this old man
back into the house oh no
now
we had no clue what the [ __ ] to do
uh
but he caught him and then carried him
back to his house yeah and he said he he
said like super creepy stuff like he
will kill him and [ __ ] in there
yeah
so oh my god turns out though he just
called the police uh
but we were like super scared like
do do we tell our parents that we threw
rocks at this house
uh because we we need help to fetch tim
like to get back to him
so we were like this we were maybe
nine and we were like trying to do the
math do we tell our parents
or is it let him die just let him die
oh [ __ ]
and well we ended up telling our parents
and we walked back to the house with our
parents and uh when we came back there
with our parents the police was were
there
and to pick up your friend
while we were super young so they just
told us to
not throw [ __ ] don't throw a rock on
people's houses yeah
you know that unlocked another memory
for me
great story by the way love yeah all
right yeah i just want to add like all
the parents all our parents involved
were like all like super they were
almost compassionate to us because
they too were super surprised
and by the way my friend tim is the only
person i know that has been in that
house except that old dude and there's
like old boxes like super like creepy
moldy and this dude apparently lives
there and never leaves
yeah what the heck in dogs
um it looks like in the show dark
totally
totally a cursed like fairy tale
that reminds me so another story about
sean
when we were in there was also like an
abandoned [ __ ] up house by our school
and it was across the street from our
during recess we had like a big field
but it was all gated off
[Music]
and during recess there was this
abandoned house and unlike you guys
with through little pebbles we were
actually degenerate [ __ ] and we would
get big ass rocks and huck it across the
street at the house trying to break its
windows nice
so every recess we would go down to the
gate get rocks and [ __ ] just love
rocks at this house
i don't know why we did that it's so
stupid and crazy i mean we were probably
about the same age you were
well sean
takes it upon himself this psycho
i i he didn't tell anyone who's going to
do this
he didn't give us any warning
he picks up a big ass rock not my
brother sean
your friend my friend
um
he he jumps the fence
goes right up to the house
and [ __ ] launches a rock right into
the window point blank shatters the
window
everybody jets we're just like what just
happened
oh my god everyone spreads out sean
jumps over the fence
the principal comes out snitch and then
sean snitched on all of us he did
because we were so young
wait the [ __ ]
we're both sean's involved in this story
what no it's sean balogue wait so he was
the one who did it and then he snitched
on you guys yeah
but he was a kid he was a kid well no
they you know
just to give them up just to give
they're like you need to tell us who
else was throwing rocks and he's like
hey they're like oh we're gonna [ __ ]
call whatever they just shake you down
but we all got suspended
i got suspended which honestly was like
the best thing ever for me i didn't care
because you just skipped but i was like
what are you wow
we just blew our minds this [ __ ] kid
and of course someone lived there and he
had to pay for the window and [ __ ]
of course someone lived there
yeah
okay
yeah but before you call him a snitch he
was like eight yeah
fair enough
still though
um snitch behavior anyone else cameron
you got one
no i really couldn't think of any
i mean i know we've had a lot of time to
think about it like i didn't think of
anything good to share all right
that's all right
anyone else sam
anyone got one that i ever didn't call
him
i have one i think i could tell
you want to come over here
uh
i can stay here it's fine okay
uh so
this is a super infamous one within my
family uh on the fourth of july one year
uh we were at a family gathering and my
uncles were in charge of lighting the
fireworks
um we had a firework punk do you know
what like a punk is
mm-hmm it's like a big sparkler that you
stick in the ground and it's meant like
you can light fireworks quickly and then
plant them so they can oh yeah yeah so
during the grand finale one of my uncles
was lighting them and turning them
around super fast and he was like
maintaining a squat the whole time
he lost his balance squatting and he
fell back onto the punk and he was
wearing swim shorts
uh we had to rush him to the er where
they had to remove like melted nylon
from his [ __ ]
and he had he had like second and third
degree burns no no no no no no so a pump
i'm still don't punk it's uh here here's
a picture of one um
i'm gonna eat your ass
it's so bad
it was so bad in the moment but it's so
funny now
oh a lighter well no it's like it's like
it looks like a big sparkler but it
doesn't
say oh
a sparkler yeah kind of yeah yeah but
it's meant for lighting fireworks
quickly right okay so he felt like the
other works he fell on the pump and his
shorts like melted to his [ __ ] oh my
god
that is horrific happy fourth of july
baby
yep
love that for him he's okay though right
oh yeah yeah he's fine
yeah so by the way i gotta i have to be
so bad i'll be right back but i have
some juicy gossip for you guys so hold
on one sec ooh
yeah
for us or the audience
everything
oh
i have no idea what he's talking about
interesting
all right
dan can you show the picture i sent
because i feel like i kind of [ __ ] talk
to my father-in-law and i want to do him
justice okay okay
all right
i mentioned that he took 25 years
i wasn't trying to [ __ ] on him it's
because he doesn't live in lebanon so
he does he's been doing this on the side
forever but what's insane to me yeah
this is like
a scarface mansion yeah
and
to put it lightly
sorry lina it's not like lena's family's
you know very wealthy we're just you
know
we're born small-time people you know so
she has like us she has like six
siblings and like a two-bedroom house
a three-bedroom house where she's lived
her whole life so after about a year two
of us dating i saw this photo after i
had came back from lebanon one so i was
like holy [ __ ] this is yours it just it
blew my mind but i guess it's normal for
a lot of arabs where they like are
building a house overseas for years um
that's like
a retirement plan or like that's the
dream sure for the family to be left for
the family
that's crazy that looks so epic did you
tell me there's no addresses there yeah
there's no addresses my brother-in-law
was telling me that like in lebanon i
don't know if it's all areas or certain
areas like if you're doing a delivery
they'll be like go up the hill
past the big tree and in between these
two trees that's the house the
wow whatever the name of the family is
so how current is this picture
this one is from last summer um lebanon
is in a [ __ ] situation right now um
and lena's dad's like it's time to cash
in on that because everything is super
cheap
so they got that house decked out now
with furniture and uh
wow so a lot of people are going
overseas right now to finish up these
projects that they've been working on
forever
that is so epic yeah
do you guys plan on ever going there um
i would like to as long as i have a big
group with me i the thought of being in
a situation that i can't talk myself out
of is very scary right like i i just i
don't know being in a foreign country
where i can't uh understand what's being
told and everything what's being said
english
knowledge there it's not like i i think
there's a good amount but i don't know i
just i need to know more about it yeah
especially because i look
white but i have like a bunch of arabic
tattoos on me
and also i have my my parents names
tattooed on me in arabic which is
actually i don't wanna say their names
but um
actually i'm just gonna stop talking but
anyways my parents names are related to
two people in lebanon who are of high
power
and uh yeah that might cause me some
problems in the wrong areas
yeah interesting
uh real quick there's a donation that i
wanted to acknowledge from the export
said hey ethan i'm the original creator
of the joe biden video guys reacted to
last show can you give me a shout out
well here it is
shout out to this
small creator and uh yeah he reached out
to me on the discord
after the show the other day because
remember we were speculating like is was
this guy a fan he's he's a he's a
trooper
more so shout out yeah more more from
the experts
we'll keep showing him brilliant
brilliant edit you did dude love you so
much
lina do you have any stories
nani that i could think of right now
all righty
no problem
all right you promised some juicy ass
gossip okay so
you guys might remember
that
faze blanks
went on david dubrick's podcast
and confronted him
for this crypto scam that he was a part
of the bunny thing what was it called uh
they were called uh
something bunnies
um check it's in the dots i actually
am not really aware of the story so
okay i'll tell you
i'll tell you from word bunnies
board bunny board bunnies just one of
these dumb
lazy pump and dump
nft crypto [ __ ] scams david was paid
to promote a very good one you know
speaking of that david had uh banks on
the podcast and [ __ ] where's that
episode you know uh well well who's from
who's doing nft scams i mean we would
never do nfc by the way it's just funny
that uh he's talking to mike malik yeah
about crypto scams and oh well he knows
a few things about ding dong
well you could tell he's like he even
said he's like i'm staying out of this
one
yeah well anyway
so faze blanks went on david dobrik's
podcast
and he confronted him he's like yo you
partook in this big crypto scam and he
called him out for it
and
why did banks
i feel like he needs to call out david
isn't he also doing stuff like that
apparently not apparently banks is an
investor
banks is like a true believer
he thinks this is going somewhere you
know we can disagree on that but from
all reports he's not really been
involved in the shady stuff at least
directly some phase people have but but
he even punished them for being involved
in that he's not been involved in any of
the shady stuff as far as we know
in fact he owns
a lot of these big ones like uh
the um
board apes or whatever like he's an
investor he believes he uh
so here he called out david dubrick
um and faze called him out he said they
offered me 700 to 500 000 to 750 up
front for story post follow i think it's
worth noting i didn't make this mistake
only because i've taken the time to
educate so a lot of these influencers
take deals brought to them by their
management
he's calling out dobrik for
look at that did you see this video it's
so embarrassing
a little more wet with some nfts if you
know what i mean so i kind of went to
the tippy top of the nft world and check
this out i got a board bunny and not
only is a board bunny but it looks like
me look at that we have the same hat
it's so sick if you're young at night
it's so sick it's so sick oh this is the
best part listen to this
so sick if you're young and naive just
like my brother
and want to get into nfts you should
check out board bunny they have
literally over 150 000 people in the
discord so it's like a ginormous ass
group chat um and yeah if you're
interested at all just start it on the
instagram page all right let me know
so apparently he got paid like half a
million bucks for that wow
which tells you it's legit
you know
if you're dumb and impressionable you
should get involved in this game i can't
believe the yeah i mean the way he just
spells it out like that if you're young
and naive
well anyway so so faze banks went on his
podcast i guess david invited him on
and face called him out they had a whole
long discussion about it and that was
like a month or two ago and it never
came out so me and me and banks being
best friends we are
i dm'd him yeah and i said hey
whatever happened
with the dobrik podcast is it true that
it just didn't air and here's what uh
banks my best buddy told me
he said
it was unfortunately cut he told me his
legal can't let it go out the way it is
wow he says it sucks too because we had
a candid interview about it
but we're working on a reshoot
he says he's been talking about it on
his instagram
um but so he says
david said my legal team won't let me
put this out wow which a tells me either
one he's lying and he just looks like a
[ __ ]
or two if his legal team really doesn't
want to let him put him out then you
know it's bad
so
that's embarrassing and additional and
special
[ __ ] uh david dobrik thank you h3h3
humor thank you phase my best buddy
with that intel
what the [ __ ] are you saying does he
mind you sharing that
i don't know
well no what i said was
i says are you gonna comment on it or
reshoot i said you want to call them to
discuss he said i have covered it all on
my instagram story so he says he's
already talked about it got it okay so
it's already public yeah he said it's
already public
so i'm assuming it's fine
can you imagine that's crazy my lawyers
won't let me put this out bro i'm so
sorry
that's what i should have told bill burr
[Laughter]
bro my lawyers won't let me put it out
this way i'm so
sorry so sorry
that's funny
that's funny
um
so that's pretty good gossip
not bad
thank you very much appreciate it
wait cnn already ended there
oh my god yeah it's already over
one month
cnn plus they start they've tried to
have their own exposure
which on face value it already is not
that nobody wants that who wants that
people who watch cnn it's like a
transient channel you just put it on
right to consume some news real fast
you're not invested
in the channel or the personalities at
all so when they come out with this you
know what was you know what it may have
been a better investment than cm cnn
plus cnn minus
got interesting uh no actually you know
what was even a better what was casey's
company they bought oh
yeah beam was a better investment than
this [ __ ]
well so
here's some stats on it right amy
you tell me which one's worse remember
queebie in casey's hands it would have
been good
sure yeah but casey's hands did they
[ __ ]
what do you mean
it wasn't i mean before he sold it if he
would have stayed and hold on to him
yeah maybe you're right very successful
so creepy or quivi or whatever the [ __ ]
yeah uh they spent
1.74
billion dollars on that and it lasted
eight months right
cnn plus
is 300 million dollars they invested in
it and it lasted one month how do you
bail out how do you bail after one month
than spending wait cnn
dollars
well cnn is um owned by is it time
warner
turner media oh it's turner right right
it's turner so yeah they're i mean
they're part of a big turning a loss
media oh
[ __ ] got him
uh yeah according to this article uh
yeah qibi
with that one uh 1.74 billion that was
218 million per month
whereas cnn spent 300 million for one
month so wow this is actually a bigger
failure than qibi apparently why did
they spend so much money on that's a
great question wait wait wait you guys
no
they sold at a cnn plus nft
cnn commander commemorative nft to
celebrate the launch as an important day
in cnn history 50 bucks check this out
87 remaining 250 total they still
haven't sold them
i'm amazed they sold annie
me too 300 million dollars later what's
that
i mean you would think that 250 is not a
lot get it
they're still for sale by the way so
oh we could
could buy all of them we got a discount
now maybe now that it's uh
now service lasted 23 days before being
shut down
yeah not even a month
wow cnn plus a streaming service that
was hyped as one of the most significant
developments in the history of cnn will
shut down cnn reporting on its own death
just one month after it launched you're
talking about yourself you know
but
yeah why did they quit after one month i
guess it's that expensive well listen to
this i'll tell you why
according to the new york times
there are
four times as many people watching our
stream right now than there were at any
given time watching cnn plus
fewer than 10 000 people at a time were
using the service but then do they did
they not count on like
needing to build that audience over time
they just want it from the get-go they
thought they had gold it's gold who
doesn't want to pay for cable
okay when disney plus launched for
example they got like millions of
subscribers
from the beginning so you need like when
they it says last week a report detailed
fewer than 10 000 people are using cnn
plus on a daily basis it's not at once
dan on a daily basis on a daily basis
it's so good so if you have like 10 000
people who sign up to subscribe it's 50
bucks or 5 bucks you're doing 50 000
dollars a month revenue on a 300 million
investment oh my god and the operational
cost is probably insane too
can't wait to report your death
[Laughter]
cnn plowed millions into the venture
rating news executives and producers
from places like abc news and nbc news
cnn had also made some deals with talent
for cnn plus
that had to on that it had to unveil
according to a person uh familiar with
what were they planning on cnn plus that
was supposed to be so interesting well
so another uh i i'm not sure i yeah
again i that whole model
i can understand it for a premium you
know
uh
service like disney plus or hbo max or
something where they're putting out
original content that you can only get
there but it's like it's the news
like you can get the news
all over the place for free right now
like cnn.com sure
cnn yeah it's like
you can't watch both at once cnn is
already on 24 hours a day like when are
you going to be watching cnn plus it's
weird that they weren't able to pull it
off to me
apparently part of it is there was some
corporate mergers the person whose like
pet project it was setting it all up had
been pushed out of the company prior to
it launching so i think they already the
new people were probably this is a
stupid idea but let's just see where it
goes and when they saw the subscriber
numbers they were like just just kill
this [ __ ] but i mean they were
advertising all around town i've seen
the billboards all over la
like trying to get like you know they
put money into marketing it would have
to be like original like sometimes cnn
has like documentaries or shows it would
have to be like something not news
related but yeah
maybe that's what you're i'm surprised
they weren't able to pull it out look if
you're if you're warner media nobody's
paying do it under a different brand i'm
just yeah cnn is just not where i'm
trying to get right a monthly
subscription
i think the nft shows that they're
trying to dab in everything dan
yeah that's that does indicate a scatter
shot approach here where it's like let's
just try and make some money however we
can
you know they paid some pr for a
shitload of money for that nft idea
uh yes actually
in one of the articles i read i saw them
referring to uh
a um consulting firm that
had supposedly projected the numbers and
uh you know they fell like 20 times
short of what the uh projections were so
i love projections it's literally the
most useless baseless [ __ ] like when
you go to shark tank they go we project
we'll do 20 million dollars next year
it's like really well next i project
next year i'll be announced as the pope
i mean what the [ __ ] are you talking
about bro you have a crystal ball it's
so stupid
um
all right so now we're at the end of the
episode so let's do a title
what do you guys think
uh
you know my vote man it's it's all about
beans and toasts
extravaganza
double triple triple down on that
i do not think people will want to watch
that
i'll click it anyway
all right let's talk about it disagree
what's chad saying
we didn't do oh we didn't do that people
are talking about depp i don't know
though it's we've been going for three
hours
i just have the funny kind of weird wild
[ __ ] from depp
i'm not familiar enough to know about
the ins and outs of the depth thing
i'm out of my depth you might say oh
fire today
[Applause]
thank you
you heard
i've amber heard oh oh
oh
he did
that yeah i took it there
well um
there's just a few moments that i
thought were kind of funny or
interesting
without like delving too deep into the
this is and that's of it are you dare i
say the depths of it
i think that's kind of pretty much the
same thing i did wow well you know we're
circling you know it's too soon to
circle yeah we're circling we're
circling
work with me all right i'll work with
you zach go and work with you
all right here's a good moment from the
uh
johnny depp
johnny depp position
oh
okay okay that's a new one this guy
on a roll this guy's on a roll
thank you
i'm just saying well zach you did the
same one i did put your hand away
is there not sound what's happening or
is he just so quiet
is there
what in god's [ __ ] what are we
watching
there's there should be audio
on september 6 2013
you
send miss
heard a text that says thank you for
your letter i love you
yes scroll down she writes thank you for
mine i read that right
you did and then you write
the only reason we go for the throat is
love
did i read that right you did
and then she writes
my throat is yours
you're going to be the death of me
but i don't care
and then you write
have other uses for your throat which do
not include injury
what a romantic other uses for your
throat
which do not include injury
sorry could you read that again
let's do your word sir right i read that
right correct
you did
but he didn't threat he mean he didn't
right
he's just a romantic guy he wants to
[ __ ] her mouth
is so gross by the way yeah that's
pretty disgusting but okay they have a
different kind of relationship right
okay they have the kind of relationship
where they uh
depose and subpoena each other in court
that's just romance yes
that's the kind of uh romance where you
have to turn over all your text messages
to court during a defamation case
you wouldn't understand
this is brutal it's brutal
having having your
your relation like
with a toxic relationship like that
having it
aired out publicly it's being broadcast
on tv millions of people watching it
so
i actually haven't been following at all
and
so this law should we do any kind of
like so brief yeah i guess just to
to give some context to what's going on
now this lawsuit because there are is a
multitude of them is him
here in the united states suing her for
defamation for
she wrote an op-ed in i think it was the
washington post
during the beginning of the whole metoo
thing claiming that he was an abuser and
hit her and all this stuff
um there's been all kinds of lawsuits
back and forth it is worth noting
uh you know he
this suit is
what what all the buzz is about is he's
brought all of this evidence including
recordings of her being abusive towards
him so he's doing the old switch route
like no you were the one who was abusive
um but
the trial isn't actually about whether
or not she abused him it's about whether
or not she lied
uh when she wrote that article and so
that's you know
we're not actually going to get an
answer from the court about whether or
not she abused him
we're just going to
get an answer about whether or not she
lied about it
um this whole thing is like live
broadcasted on yeah
yeah that's crazy yeah
so yeah people are people are watching
it
well apparently she's [ __ ] in his bed
did you know that i haven't heard about
that
and there's all these pictures of johnny
like
just totally trashed like
i don't know let's watch this one let's
see
johnny johnny yes papa eating sugar no
papa telling lies no papa johnny johnny
he says he looked at it on his foot on
his phone i'll rule the objection as the
photograph
what was the photograph of mr depp
[Music]
it was a it was a
it was a photograph of the bed
our bed
and on
my side of the bed
um
was human fecal matter
wait can you can you try that again
johnny
human fecal matter
oh there's a soundbite he's doing a
dramatic reading of the quartz
[Music]
why do you say it like that human fecal
matter
was human fecal matter
[Music]
by the way you gotta be really nuts to
take a [ __ ] in someone's bed out of
anger
and i feel like that's not even disputed
right like he has a picture of it
her lawyer indicates that it was from
the dog it's all disputed does it look
like a human [ __ ] or a dog [ __ ] they're
arguing over every inch of all of this
so i mean you know
that's awesome though [ __ ] in the
bed out of anger yeah it was
on twitter it was running yesterday
amber turd yeah
dude i just
can't these people just like messy
they've both destroyed each other's
lives i feel like and
like damn y'all could have just kept it
all private and moved the [ __ ] on
i guess she started with that op-ed
right i don't know i don't know nothing
about this whole thing is like i don't
know man
all i know is she apparently [ __ ] in the
bed
apparently
i have seen pictures of it
it's ambiguous it could have been a dog
it could have been a human right
have you guys seen it it was hard to
tell from that i have not seen i did not
know look just google amber turd and see
if it shows up
for your own sake don't put it on the
screen yes i got it i understood why
it wasn't a good time to go down there
um oh there it is
what do you what's your take here she
put it up for ela but don't switch to it
again
oh oh i was gonna say it just depends on
the dog but i'm seeing
from this post that it was a yorkie uh
yeah this doesn't i mean you guys have
you working we'll tell you show me dorky
poop
but that looks like not a yorkie poop to
me
yeah this looks like a vintage poop it's
really messy
it's really messy little kind of
diarrhea isn't it
that's a nasty one it doesn't really
look like a bigger poop though either
it looks just like i don't know it's
just like if they had a big dog
i would
say i can't tell
no it's too big for a yorkie exactly
yeah so
and that does lean towards it it's like
a big puddle i don't think i don't think
shredder poops like that
is there paper in there
is this oh yeah is there one where you
wonder if it's like taken from somewhere
and thrown there no it could be
could be interesting you didn't show
that right hand
okay thank you
here's the dog oh and it's not just a
yorkie it's like a toy
cup yeah oh there's no shot that [ __ ]
was like the size of his whole
body there's no shot that that was the
dog that was from the dog yeah that
seems unlikely zero percent chance
that's from the dog yeah yeah
somebody in the chat said i know
three women that have [ __ ] on their ex's
belongings one hundred percent she [ __ ]
on the bed three why did you do that
i'm not calling we need to speak to you
how do you know what three separate
incidents women [ __ ] on
what do you what do you what's your
theory that women just got angry and
[ __ ] all over the place
well maybe it's just the crowd they're
running with who oh my god is this a
common tactic
as far as i know i don't know any
anybody that's i never heard anybody
those emotional women yeah i tell you
what man i'm tired women [ __ ] on my
belongings
it's the fourth time a woman [ __ ] on my
belongings man
my wife left a whopper poo on my bed
there you go
i think it's it was from when we talked
about this like two years ago yeah when
this first the story first broke that's
how long this has been going through the
courts so that's a text i guess john
johnny
do you feel he's a little too old to go
by johnny i feel weird when i call him
johnny johnny
age
independent really no you can be like
it just seems like a little youthful
what would it just jonathan yeah john
jonathan death john john is like not
johnny that
he's not a johnny he's a genius johnny
that it's a brand new [ __ ]
johnny he's not just a giant like 50.
i don't know he's not just a drunk i
fart in the bathroom
i've changed
does anyone feel like johnny he's too
old for johnny
no just me
no you're on your own he's definitely
not a john
jonathan
weirdly weirdly
jonathan depp
doesn't bother me as much he's not a
john john depp this is like jonathan
it's time to be at a certain age you
become jonathan depp is he's johnny
johnny
john what about johnny cassinator johnny
cash johnny dab
right
what johnny cash yeah johnny cash i mean
he's the heck
he should have been jonathan too
think so johnny knoxville
jonathan
his real name is john christopher depp
the second
that why can't he be that he's kind of
badass
the second
there he is
my actual response to that
was
i mean i laughed
it was so
outside
it was so bizarre
so so grotesque
i could only laugh um oh man this is so
weird
why is she getting she's up there
looking like hillary clinton or some
[ __ ] i don't know
the whole vibe is like giving me hillary
laugh
um
and um
so i did not go down there that day
i did not go down there that day my
friends
there was a
massive what did you call it
human fecal matter no no the sound bite
you played a whopper a massive
whopper poo on my bed
uh amber's lawyers accused johnny of
being obsessed with elon musk uh oh
guilty guilty
okay can i ask who the what the [ __ ] is
this that's two likes where'd you even
find this you know how long the exact
we're looking for our videos yeah all
like pro johnny edits fan cam we're
trying to keep it neutral because yeah
the internet is flooded with like yeah
johnny stands putting together meme
edits
that you know
so finding just does seem like in
general and again i'm not familiar
enough to have an opinion honestly i
haven't followed it at all
but people hate amber and love johnny
johnny yes papa
at the moment he seems to be winning the
battle in the court of public opinion
definitely yeah but i feel like he has
been for a while
uh
perhaps yeah i mean people hate her like
hate her
well the thing is is that
you know what did she do other than the
poop like what are we talking about well
the the big incident that people point
to
was the one where she
was it was like a wine bottle or
something that she threw and it like
deeply gashed his finger to the point
that it almost like cut it off
people hate her for ruining his life and
they think she lied so they think she
falsely accused him of something they
falsely accuse him of of abuse and then
they actually think he she abused him
so people like
hate her
she allegedly cheated on him with elon
musk yeah i heard that i don't think
that i think that's real
oh that's why he's obsessed with elon
right because she she
was with elon
mm-hmm
i heard elo moss is a witness or is it
supposed to be oh my god no way really
he's going to get calling i called to
the stage elon musk that's wild
yeah
so so so basically uh yeah there's
something she punched him and hit him
all the time yeah
well there's a recording of it where she
admits to hitting him and she's like
don't be a baby don't be a baby that's
not a hit comments are she is the abuser
she absolutely abused and lied about him
people there's been a lot of character
uh testimony in favor of johnny all this
a lot of his exes came out and made
character statements saying that he was
never violent he never abused them they
amicably part ways and that's crazy so
he has a lot of character testimony from
his exes
because usually when people are violent
there's a there is a
pattern right people are saying she
punched him threw pans at him so in the
chat people are
well if that's all true she is really
evil then
right
i don't see anyone here supporting
johnny let's do a pull
no amber you mean nobody's supporting
her right right yeah who do you support
amber turd
or
johnny
johnny yes papa
i'm gonna do a third option that they
are both abusive to each other to uh
both just say both yeah right
equal blame whose
side are you on
johnny
amber
yeah we gotta end the podcast soon
[Music]
let me ask you a different question i
can't listen to music
here let me watch this way you guys vote
y'all found this two-like post
you'll find out
we've got
eighty-one percent johnny there it is
second place both to blame at sixteen
perc or actually just jumping there's
twenty nobody in amber turkey yeah we
got three percent on amber only three
percent are in amber turds corner it's
pretty wild
so no there is a fact about this that i
should point out
yeah
there already was one case where he sued
the sun in the uk for libel or definite
i guess it's libel because it was
written right
because they published an article saying
that uh you know that he was like a wife
beater
and he sued them for libel and he lost
that
so in that previous case it was found
that it was
you know
at least true enough that they had not
libeled him by labeling him
a wife beater um i don't think that
means anything no
and again it's just like the con
these are very narrow that's why i was
pointing out with this case is it's not
actually even this trial isn't
determining whether or not she abused
him it's determining whether or not she
lied about
him abusing her i mean he's suing her
for defamation right
but the fact that he lost his case
doesn't mean that it doesn't mean
anything
i don't know what's the defamation libel
laws in the uk but they're pretty
intense actually
losing doesn't doesn't mean anything
but anyway what's this clip in addition
to that she also was dating elon musk by
this time you'll find out that mr dev is
obsessed with elon musk but she's dating
him so he gives 500 000.
that's it
what's that do for me
that's going viral with music that one
because it's funny that he just laughed
at her defense attorney saying that
uh he's going viral for what he's just
saying a version of that with like goofy
music yeah it has gone viral he found
one that didn't have the music for you
know copyright reasons okay
very good
uh oh here's the pro johnny edits you
just add these awesome i want to see
them oh these are these all have music
though
that's the one i sent discord was one of
those i want pro johnny edit objection
yeah okay i can't hear it
it's just him laughing and being like oh
amber heard says that johnny would hang
out with old people playing guitar
is that a
bad thing
and those old people happen to be like
alice cooper keith richards
it's just a rolling stone you know
even without the context it's still not
a bad thing sure yeah but i like how she
just described
justin
say
about feeling insecure
she told me she didn't like hanging out
in his house with his friends because it
it was boring and they were all old men
playing guitars and it wasn't
interesting to her
what else did miss heard say that's it
interesting
johnny speaking with opposing counsel
yes papa
yes papa
texted paul bettany correct can you not
put music
this is why we're finding two like
versions of these clips because so many
of them have like goofy music on it well
anyway you guys get the idea
where yeah so there you go free johnny
depp or whatever or skit or kill johnny
depp free him whatever you whatever you
guys say
awesome didn't read
what's the one copy
no but free johnny depp you know
amber turd
those of you guys who found the vlog to
be offensive i'm sorry you did for those
of you who didn't find it to be
offensive i'm sorry they did
worst apology ever
yeah well 97 are in favor of johnny so
so [ __ ] amber turd i hope she burns in
hell i'm just saying that too please
don't you know just leave me out of it
yes the i'm going to end the poll 76
johnny 21 both to blame yeah three
percent uh um
[ __ ] amber turd
and
people are joking that the three percent
is their their finger slip when they
went to go vote apparently there's a lot
of like he's got all these tags and
audio recordings he has a lot more hard
evidence than she does from from my
understanding
and stuff so yeah that definitely uh
[Music]
yeah
so i hope she dies
no oh no not too far i'm just i listen i
just don't want people to be mad at me
just tell me what to say
johnny depp forever amber turd i hope
she [ __ ]
perishes in a burning fire no too far
too far i hope she gets what's coming to
her
uh
i hope someone shits in her bed yeah
exactly see how you feel
there you go
no of course i don't wish death on her
but something slightly worse than death
uh a sleeping with keemstar
oh no no no no
two too hard worse than that
too far worse than death
cruel and unusual
your punishment is you have to spend the
evening with keemstar in his basement
bar
kill me
no
daddy i'll take the electric carrier on
her
oh can you find that tweet uh show me
before we go this is the last thing
keemstar's got this tweet pin that it's
just so funny i just want to acknowledge
that it's like the funniest thing ever
people have been circulating this fake
tweet of keemstar
i'm pretty sure people know it's fake
and they're just [ __ ] with them but
keemstar is panicking
he pinned this is this still pinned yeah
so he pinned this this was on white
people twitter
and it's been going
all over the place it was like really it
was it's circulating it's on reddit
so the fake tweet of keemstar's
it says i don't give a [ __ ] what anyone
says sex with younger and less
experienced girls is always better the
problem with when i've been with lots of
men is that they're far more prone to
say mean things about your dick and how
bad you are at sex now what's funny
about this tweet is that although he
never wrote that you know that that's
what he feels and that's why it's so
funny
or at least it seems plausible enough to
enough people
that they continue to circulate it yeah
people look at that and be like yeah
that seems
so whatever you guys do do not spread
this fake tweet around the internet yeah
this is not real he did not actually say
that but so do not spread this around
the internet you guys
because it really bothers keemstar and
the last thing we want is to spread this
fake tweet all around the internet ride
my [ __ ] dick yes totally
so keemstar uh he had to pin it and he
said i can't believe i even have to
address this be but someone made this
fake tweet of me on reddit a few weeks
ago and i just assumed most people knew
it was fake every single day keeps
getting more viral and now it's taking
over tick tock for the record i never
tweeted exactly he never tweeted this so
don't spread it all over the internet
i'm sorry i made a mistake because we
don't want keemstar to get bothered by
this fake tweet that everyone's
spreading around the internet that he
never said
but even though we know that that it's
true what we know it's that he thinks
that but he never wrote it i'm busted
it's so funny though do people actually
think that this is real like who would
write the problem with women people
i think that says more about keemstar
but just imagine the problem with women
who have been with boston is that
they're more prone to saying things
about your dick and how bad you are in
sex why would you write that
that's [ __ ] hilarious bro
people say stop touching your face i
have a headache
i have like a pressure point here when i
have a headache i
i push here in it i don't know why it
alleviates my [ __ ]
pain
how did you guys think it was real
that's so funny that you thought it was
real
that's awesome
i think when i first saw it i was like
oh my god i have to go check if this is
real
kind of like that was my reaction
well the first part is believable i
don't give a [ __ ] if anyone says sex
with younger and less experienced girl
is always better
that i mean he he had such
like crazy tweets in the
yeah not that hard to believe like the
one about the women over 40 that are
people unattractive to him yeah it
sounds like a fake tweet if i saw that i
might think that was so dumb yeah
um people a lot of people saying that uh
they thought it was real
i thought it was real well there you go
so it's not fake so sit do not you guys
understand not real
it's not a real tweet but so don't post
it to tick tock
don't post it to twitter don't post it
to reddit don't post it to instagram
youtube whatever wherever you post
wherever you think people would enjoy
this fake tweet do not post it there
because it really bothers keemstar
you're right you know what i'm saying
right right romeo and julia
yeah don't spread it guys come on
it seems like it does really good on
tick tock so don't spread it there
[Music]
someone said i i physically know in my
being that keemstar is bad at sex
somebody said something fresh and fit
would say yet unironically
they probably would oh yeah for sure
like that really
that's like straight out of their
playbook
oh it's so fun wait so wait wait before
we go we have to decide on a title
so this isn't serious keemstar if
keemstar tweet that's totally 100 fake
the one time we have to defend keemstar
no yeah yeah totally defending him don't
post it
i should post it on tick tock and be
like this is 100 not a real tweet
i mean that's exactly what he did when
he any controversy he's in with the
whole leafy thing or uh saying that he's
theodore's father or whatever dirty [ __ ]
he said he goes i'm not the father i
didn't sleep with this person i didn't
do this that's his uh that's his go-to
that's a fake tweet yeah that's not what
i'm doing i'm trying to defend her yeah
i actually love that we have nothing to
do with it i got nothing to do with this
tweet
that was dreamed up by somebody else
you know
a 10 year old fan right away
say that again what
a 10 year old fan right away whoa what
does that mean keem any more context to
that
can you elaborate we do need to um head
back all right title so we talked about
keemstar we talked about johnny depp
amber turd we told stories
and we did ace family
ace family
we did uh at the top of the document
what do we do
kim kardashian kim k we did a little
taste test of some beans on top beans on
toast so what are you guys feeling here
for a title what's the most compelling
top topic
i mean a lot of people beans on amber
turd someone suggested yeah a lot of
people want us
though yeah i think keep that one in the
title amber turret yeah
free johnny depp and amber
like actually amber turd oh and tim
poole someone said tim stool and amber
turd
yo
that's good but it's good but like it
nobody's gonna click that as good as it
is keemstar ace family and johnny depp
walk into a bar
nobody cares about gaming i'm just
reading comments yeah
i mean people are liking tim still on
amber turd
that is pretty epic but i don't know
that people are gonna click that
i mean it's a big storm then at least
that amber part's a big story
all right but just let's do topics let's
narrow it down so top one is
amber johnny depp v amber turd
second one is tim pool
third ace family i don't give a [ __ ]
about i think kim kardashian kim k
beans and toast no because people are
going to vote for that and i'm not doing
beans and toast
you're asking me to put up a poll for
them oh we do yeah for a while we get
that we're gonna get i wanna see what
the people think we can just put all
those three yeah just put all of those
in the turtle that's great okay cool
we're on a roll there okay cool then do
that so we got and then
uh what else do we do
temple kim kay
beans on toast
am i actually writing amber turd or am i
writing her name what about just just do
a real name okay what about me and face
banks become friends and i defend
keemstar
[Laughter]
it's pretty good that's so [ __ ] angry
i'm so [ __ ] angry
keemstar l
team start another alpha game star right
[Music]
so what do you got dan
johnny depp versus amber hurd
uh
kim k
[Music]
beans on toast
no b boom wait what about tim stool
nobody cares about tim's stool beans on
toast says more pull than tim stool yes
unironically
we talked about it for a long time on
wednesday
amber turd
defending keemstar people like that
because it's so unexpected
at the very [ __ ] last second of a
three hour podcast though simple as
throats
tim pool is the roast wow
kim shartatian
and amber turd surro box
kim shart
[Music]
oh god we're still alive yeah we are
yeah we are alive okay
all right
put it in the put it in the uh discard
let me see the title that you wrote out
okay
by the way this is the real tweet that
he wrote which is pretty nuts yeah
you guys keep telling me to date someone
my own age i googled 39 year old woman i
will not be listening to you guys
if you remember where you were on 9 11
i'm not interested
and then the pictures she showed were
from missing women it is it is this is
totally equivalent it is
so i guess i can see why people think it
was real right but these and then the
best part is these are all missing women
not all or two of them are somewhere
what
holy god
i send it to you by the way if you want
to peep that nice rod
that crypto [ __ ]
johnny depp versus amber heard kim k
defending keemstar kim k [ __ ] kim k just
do defending keemstar
all right
after that
nobody cares about kim k right i mean
who cares i don't know i wouldn't i'm
curious about this
exactly you wouldn't either no you want
to put defending keemstar no i
personally i
don't no i think it's good
not good
why isn't it good because just the off
chance that one person
will not know that it's a joke is not
worth it
good point i would like to change my
mind and there's my case there's and
there's some some people are
just hate him to the point of not even
wanting to laugh at him and just don't
want to hear about it you know what i
mean
yeah i'm even seeing no keem stop okay
there it is
remove key kardashian
just kim kardashian vs roblox
keem kardashian kim shartashian
shartashian
tim turd
or tim
amber turd
timpu
all right let's just go for it
and then beans on toast
which is basically johnny depp versus
amber heard kim no no
we need a scat play on johnny depp
uh number two that's not good
johnny deff the kate
johnny definitely
all right
the [ __ ] we're talking about
johnny depp i guess johnny depp versus
amber turd tim stool
kim shartashian
and beans and toast johnny poop
how does that help kim
he's trying he's trying
johnny dupe johnny depoop
johnny duke johnny john johnny dookie
does anyone have any ideas i'm sure the
chat's going to throw some on yeah
johnny johnny dump and johnny
dump
he's like a weird scat
granny dump versus amber
[Laughter]
johnny deuce
johnny dew it's interesting that i feel
like that's
i think dump
is funny okay so we have johnny dump
versus amber turd
or johnny duke
johnny dookie tim stool kim shartashian
and beans and toast
beans and toast
after dark number seven sunny fecal
matter
are we gonna get yellow for all the [ __ ]
references most likely so then let's
then i'm out oh why it's not worth it
bro we got yellow in the last episode
i have no sponsors and all my episodes
are getting yelled at job
someone said johnny
depp oh johnny defecation case against
amber turd
oh
the deposition just beans on toast yes
the beans on toast special extravaganza
no
really no not really
thank you just do the regular version
all right someone said
go back we're doing the boring here we
got here's the thumbnail eula
that's fire that's fire i clicked that
is not fire that is fire no that will
not be something i would like the meme
shirt
[Laughter]
all right what's the title working title
it's
i guess johnny depp versus amber heard
tim poole kim kardashian beanzone
wait write out a new one because look
write it write it in discard i feel like
we could get away with stool
turd is a it's not worth it we're gonna
get yellow i can run into business here
not worth it
about amber took a massive steamer
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh amber juicer
like that
ember
yeah
all right new title johnny depp versus
amber heard tim poole kim kardashian's
beans on toast yes there we go oh so
boring it's so much worse
[Music]
all right
fine
[Laughter]
johnny dumper's amber turd
is so much better
you guys think anyone gives a single
[ __ ] about temple on kim kardashian
though no not well kim k yeah but temple
now what do you guys think yeah temple
no you can take him out [ __ ] him
i like well then just put kim kardashian
vs roblox nobody cares about that either
johnny depper's amber turd beans on
toast [ __ ] bonanza
do a poll do a poll if nobody cares
about these topics why didn't we we only
talked about johnny depp at the very end
that's what i'm saying it's dudu
all right do a pull dan would do you
care in the title do you think it's
helpful to include
tim poole
you do tim paul kim kardashian or both
or none
and now be honest we're doing this is a
serious survey we need to know
if having this in the title is
interesting to you
this is high level market research
i think if you want to be involved in
youtube in any way this is great
research like to actually see how much
goes into it
i'm sure a lot of people are grateful
i'm grateful for the market research
for the real
everybody says neither some people say
kim k maybe that's enough people
interested in kim k
nobody gives a [ __ ] about tim pool in
his slot buckets yeah
[Music]
well some people say both
give him kids
kim k is looking like it's worth today
yeah
so let's do kim k vs roblox
you do realize we spend so much time
talking about temple and nobody cares
about him well it's funny but nobody's
[ __ ] we didn't actually talk about
tim pool as much as we talked about slot
buckets for
which the slot buckets were funny i love
people go you're going after sponsors
i'm like the slot buckets
going after the slot buckets they're not
dropping him he's the only one that will
[ __ ] promote that [ __ ] are you
kidding me
you know you know they pay temple for
the slot bucket spots in swamp bucket
exactly that's why he has somebody in
his home yeah exactly oh
god
all right johnny depper's amber heard
no remove the tin pool yeah it's gone
kim jong-un
is on toast oh my goodness just copy
paste somewhere i am i am i am there you
go johnny that versus amber heard kim
kardashian vs roblox roblox beans take
the beans on toast up for christ's sake
what do you mean that's the best part
nobody's even reading them all right
leave the beans on no take it out oh my
god
all right what harm could it do what the
[ __ ] is even this i want the beans on
toast i'd rather see no i'd rather see
amber heard than a beans on toast
[Laughter]
but like
three minutes ago you wanted it to be
funny now you don't want to be funny
anymore yeah because i can't well it's
not funny
what's funny about beans on toast you
just want poop in the title yeah
it's fun beans on toast is funny after
all the scat references
on it's by itself it's not
without that
you're right
a lot of people said both though so if
you include both you're a lot of people
it's the third one it's at the bottom of
the poll i'm saying if you include both
and simple together that's seventeen
percent it's not no
okay so um
so what's the new title and remove the
[ __ ] beans on
exactly what i just sent to you minus
the beans on toast so get the hell get
the beans on toast out of there and let
me see amber turn my god you wait in the
thumbnail
cam
copy that cam
[Music]
what the hell is going on around here
cam do you hear me he said got it ian
has the thumbnail today because uh oh
that was ian i was doing the movie how
are you switching and making a thumbnail
and he's got he's pretty monitored baby
he's the great he's the goat what the
goat how's that possible
i mean he's got three monitors he's got
vmix on one and photoshop on the other
side what are you afraid of
don't you have this okay this the
camera's just on you it's impressive a
little cut little f5 little impressive
he's like the guy from spirited away
he was in the engine with eight arms
and that's right and the little soot
creatures i want to see that fan art
somebody somebody give me ian is the uh
doctor guy from the united way all right
so i think we're settled then
johnny depp versus amber turd kim
kardashian vs roblox
it's all in the thumbnail
this is so awesome okay we gotta go okay
this is epic
what happened
that we figured out the [ __ ] title
yeah it's great i'd agree i just said it
was epic yeah
one final shout out to the cards that
we're selling very limited edition will
never be sold again right forever ever
the h3
link in the description trading
oh
i didn't know we had a trailer
yep made by cameron
wait why didn't we show this we're
trying to told you to
no well amy's put the phone in my hand
and then like we're all set up later
it's fine i'm just going to
then set it and you're like whose hand
was that it's already here that was sam
oh this hand i don't know that's right
no that's that's a rap traitor bro yeah
well there was a woman's hand i wasn't
sure who's here that was sam that's um
yeah okay
there it is grab trader is the ghost
dude the goat
the freaking
[Applause]
all right we got to go
we're all good we got our thumb i hope
you guys have fun we'll see you on
monday everybody everybody have a great
great
weekend it's friday baby
oh
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
you